welcome to the iron Lord podcast episode
number 19 and we are back in the
building fresh off the West Coast trip
from e3 and it's a special Father's Day
edition and we got the usual suspects at
the round table once again let's start
off with my brother from another mother
the co-host with the coat knows my man
Lord addict how we doing sir
pretty good man how you guys doing I'm
still kind of tired man I'm gay I was
asleep the jetlag drill yeah that and I
played Xcode literally half the night
yeah we talked about this give it up
definitely real of course we got the
solo player single player experience
detect general my man Lord sovereign
how we doing sir doing all right man
doing all right
I'm in the same boat as Lord Alec just
trying to get out from under this letter
jetlag cloud man just trying to catch up
it's a little slow going
it's a little slow going but hey hey to
be back nice back at the table and of
course my main the excess gamer
oh man who does maybe laughing a bit
there's nothing less than the premium
uber experience
oh my little kick how we doing sir
Leo we don't fantastic on the tech
general mmm but um anyway Oh God shoot
the shot um anyway were no yeah I feel
you out with the jetlag thing I'm
operating in Cali time to be honest with
you because it's like four o'clock in
the morning I'm feeling like just one of
my thoughts ox is shaking a peek at you
I jumped in the car it was it's so good
to jump in your car and drive you so
gasps yes I am lutely
I don't know I really can't stand
everybody else having control of Holley
driving me so now it's great to be back
I've been chomping at the bit for this
podcast this podcast has to get out
there for these people and this is it
hey yeah of course it is myself Lord
Cognito here and our first off just
wanna apologize obviously we had some
initial plans that we wanted to do for
the podcast Walla
Anthony however some things were
promised to the Lords that did not come
to fruition on a technical side is we
made a roundtable decision that we would
not give anything less than the best
quality while out there and again we
apologize to be definitely a lot of
stuff going we still still still have
stuff coming but um we just wanted to
talk about that as well but yeah I'm
doing good and I wanted to start off now
normally usually sorta roundtable with
you know what we've been playing and
obviously we were eagerly so the Lord's
work so you know playing a lot of things
so I just want to do a little different
in the sense of you know let's start off
with you Lord addict as far as like what
were your standouts as far as
experiences not necessarily conferences
because we're gonna get into that but
just any standout moments or memories or
maybe people you met that kind of thing
so Lord addict I'll let you set it off
uh meeting tough was pretty good I taxi
- yeah I mean there's a few is
particular I think one of the biggest
things as I met the halo wars - those I
met the sea thieves I have a I don't
know if I I met a so for I think he he
said he was the love he was a lead the
lead person over Naughty Dog I don't
know if exactly if it was him but the
way he was carrying himself I would not
be surprised because he was really
really arrogant it was pretty much like
extremely bad like I gotta go into
detail what this man was saying in this
in his destiny line but it was not good
he had all been something because he
didn't have a he didn't have an
appointment he just walked straight
through mmm
stick interesting okay the Lord
sovereign this was your first III very
first experience so any standout moments
any cool people you met that you uh want
to talk about for me I just think in
general just meeting like meeting swat
and Panda and whiskey and a monkey and
just like the entire extended ina Lord's
family meeting meeting the ticke guys so
it's good to finally put face you know
faces to all these absolutely associated
with online and for me all of that is
brand new so just to be able to meet
these people and you know I talked to
them hang out with them that was really
cool um in terms obviously I didn't have
access to certain things but I think I
honestly I was I was sort of happy with
the way the convention went in terms of
like there was a lot of people there
that place was packed and honestly as
gamers I I say we should be pretty proud
of how we behaved and how we acted like
honestly I didn't see a single incident
everybody was like really being polite I
mean it was just peep assertive people
passionate to play their games um you
know and it was just a very cool
experience it was crazy it was packed
and hard to get to anything I'm sure
there was moments though we might have
heard about them but I'm sure there was
no actually there there was zero
incidents they reported in in LA yeah
there was news it's a fashion girl that
was partying sorry oh she wasn't missing
she wasn't missing yeah and uh she was
in a casino gambling girl is oh yeah yes
honestly that to me I was I was pretty
much in that you know on the show floor
all three days pretty much the entire
day and like honestly like I didn't
really see anything like it was very
just very cool people trying to you know
be as accommodating as possible ran into
a couple of people you know that I
listened to a podcast like IGN guys um
you know obviously Sean Finegan um
Dustin the Gary um the kind of funny
guys ran into Nick scarpino to the
picture with them so everybody was
pretty cool very nice you know uh you
know and and you know that it's
difficult for them
because it's work for them they're
working very hard so to give you a
couple of minutes at a time right it was
very gracious oh yeah man good times all
around
Dokdo Lord King you're no stranger to
this III rodeo how was your experience
any standout with any cool people you
would have a lot of my standout moments
were um seeing the guys again from past
fan fests are linking up with some of
our guys that we play online with and
talk to the same thing like SWAT panda
shout-out to hot monkey love and really
coming through and making it you know
his own he really didn't get a chance to
see the actual convention I thought he
would have had a great time there mom
but he did come out to hang out with the
iron Lords and it was greatly
appreciated my standout moments again
was my conversation with film Aaron
Greenberg actually coming up behind me
giving me a hug and saying what's up I'm
glad you're here
that felt like really good I was like yo
I'm here and it's boom like wound up in
the corner and he was he was just
chilling and nobody was saying anything
and I looked over and I said this is the
do to change my fighting game viewpoint
the rest of my life and talk about it
and I got all shook his hand and I said
oh I said uh is it okay that I I'm six
full told you that someone pounds on a
very intimidating guy and he's looking
like you could take anything you like I
was like I just wanna take a picture
which I'm so humbled by his presence and
he was just such a humble and gracious
individual then I took the picture with
him and honestly that is my probably my
standout moment because that was
something that I didn't anticipate
something that I couldn't even dream of
in my wildest dream that I seen him just
standing there without an armed security
around him he was just such a great
individual and I'm really appreciative
for the hard work that he put in for his
last game I told him and thank you so
much for justice too because it's
incredibly creaking Fantasia
that's the game yeah I mean laws you
guys are on it I mean you know obviously
it's not first rodeo but upfront want a
shot I gotta lecture a lot of shoutouts
on the experience is always is just it's
always fun to see and just to see
people's new reaction you know for that
first time and stuff but first of all I
want a shout out to the Microsoft team
because um you know for those of us who
did have access to fan fest Microsoft
really puts on an amazing event and it's
such it's so cool to be able to be able
to touch the execs and there's no ego
and they make mingling around the people
you know cream salad I wanna shout him
out you know Erin cream for coastal
areas he was in rare form and it's
always great to see Mike Ibarra and
those guys and just to talk it up and
just talk gaming and you just see how
these guys are just real appreciative
you know as far as um you know people I
met I mean like like a lord sovereign
saying just put in the faces you know
shout out to all the txr guys and I'm an
inferno we always shop it up southbound
I saw you this year I remembered you so
the judge well mark I had some great
talks with him oh and Tim dog of course
the legendary Tim dog you know we should
be chopped it up with with the aula tick
so we chopped it up with our tank you
know Cal nicodemus I met for the first
time shout hear my own you start off you
know I'm saying like you know it's just
running into people and just you know
having those conversations also want to
shout out to a couple of actually people
I met actually at fan fest my Canadian
team from Montreal avoid Canadian Steve
and a groovy bird because that was
actually their first fan fest experience
and there's nothing like being on a
conference and just to see the Wonder in
people's faces it was really amazing and
um yeah a deluxe legal so many people I
can go on and on and on but you know for
all the people that I didn't mention
obviously you know we it was fun just to
talk gaming and and link it up with
people and no fire team chat the list
goes on I can go on all day but shout
out to everybody that I got a chance to
get in contact with it I even waited on
a line with you off of gaming and then
we had some fun man it was another good
e3 so on we don't get into it but Lords
have a lot to discuss and um we want to
do this
III recap
addition right so as we know there was
about five six individual press
conferences so I want to save the big
three for last I want to save you know
um Nintendo I want to save Microsoft I
want to save Sony you know I want to
save them for last and um I want to get
into obviously the third party guys like
the EA the Bethesda and the Ubisoft so
let's start off with Bethesda we also
know that they had a press conference
and um they had some things to show so I
want to get into what did everyone feel
about the desert press conference and
their impressions so anybody can jump in
and jump on around take me take it okay
um all going on Bethesda I didn't get a
invite to the show on you in you know
the conference this year and I would
love to go to the party I heard it was
crazy
um I ranked of Bethesda as because the
software companies they're not going to
be ranked in the hardware section so I'm
ranking Bethesda as a see um because I
felt that the show picked up for them
towards the end I know everybody's like
yeah the Elder Scrolls online and the VR
you're the VR presence thank you thank
you for giving us games that we can
actually play in a regular system and
the VR and I noticed that it was on the
vibe the vibe is the only system VR
system right now that is powerful enough
and capable enough to facilitate regular
gaming in that VR space so that was you
know pretty good I didn't get a chance
to test it out because the lines on it
was ridiculous um their online card game
beautiful game um but again this is
watered-down stuff that could be added
to anybody's show and um I have a
particular bias towards software
companies making conferences because I
feel they're unnecessary and in the
grand scheme of everything and I think
they're getting ahead of they selves and
black as far as putting a car in front
of
on the horse uh by trying to have a
conference
you're not necessary so you get a C and
I'm not gonna give you anything above a
C because that inflates the ego so yeah
you warned to see and the looking did a
good play before Basel um your feeling
is that alright cuz the argument could
be made there like bethesda was the one
of the first kind of like to break off
for the dorm right and to have their own
you know press conference and stuff so
like and in the past I would agree with
you like you know I mean actually I said
now I do agree but in the past a lot of
people would say hey man that was
warranted but is it one of those things
that you think they don't have enough
content every year or like what is your
main thing about like not liking their
parties to do their uh that you know
they're only three my main thing instead
of you know and they're not to bleed
into the big three conference my main
three my main thing is now it looks like
you have the big three that comes down
and poaches from the these other
conferences and takes their best game
now when they go in and they take their
best game and they put it on this stage
that software company can't display that
game in its entirety and or its
wholeness to be seen now then there's
games that are left with that software
company that they have to wrap a show
around so then you have a you know B and
C titles that are being expanded on that
are rarely not warranted because the
other you know sort of hardware
companies didn't want those games and
they're saying we're going to make a
conference because the games that we
want to show aren't being picked by the
other you know big three now maybe
Microsoft and Sony needs to extend their
shows so they can accommodate some of
these guys and I don't think there's
enough handshaking between software and
hardware companies to come to that
comfortable medium where this is our
title and could you you know give us at
least a two minute thing or a dirty
second thing on it so that the world can
see it
and that's where they spawn these little
uh shows the software shows that I'm
particularly
a fan though gotcha okay fair enough I
see we going with it I see what you
going is that what you got him because
he gave it that strong see here to see
anything else will make them gasp stuff
that do it again next year Tom came on
is gonna be happy yes one hears this but
uh I want to move it over to a man at it
love it how do you feel about a but
there's a short leash but des ursins
trash D move on Oh
shots fired there was nothing that on
got you excited or that it was not one
timing I'm not a I'm not a wolfenstein
person and I feel like you know people
that gave it a little bit of a pass was
because they were such fan of
Wolfenstein and you know those selective
games and I'm just like the opposite
like I'm not really a first person
shooter unless your tail over destiny
and I'm like move on continue okay but
they did show dishonored DLC which you
know is a problem in itself they show
dishonor DLC but that's what I mean some
Valley plays there's a little bit some
DLC okay so what letter would you give
it mmm probably your year score thank
you so you give y'all both so we got
both equal to Lord
alright loss sovereigns if you might
break the seat I yeah I don't think
we're breaking anything I would tensed I
had to say I'm rating them as a whole
I'm not separating Hardware from
software so I if we're going one through
six this is number six already early
preview of Lord something right a little
earlier yeah sorry about that
um look but honestly honestly they
really they didn't have enough content
for the own for the for their own press
conference in their press conferences 40
minutes why would you rent out a hall
and have all these people come out there
to watch this conference when a like
Pete Hines was on stage for very short
amount of time after that it was just
honestly trailers so if that's the case
just give
a direct give me a Nintendo like direct
door though don't be saying that where
people in the comment section I don't
want no company doing anything like
Nitin I hear you but you be honest that
way you don't you know you don't dilute
the message you put out what you need to
put out and people don't feel like
they've sort of been robbed when it's
when they're sitting there watching DLC
for a game that came out last year which
is cool it's fine and honestly the stuff
that they showed was great but it didn't
warrant having their own presentation it
was it was very short you would think
you know when they came out with fallout
4 and they announced fallout 4 they blew
that out um and then they talked about
praise so it was I understand having a
conference in error in that respect when
people are waiting for Fallout 4 you
know damn near a decade you know I think
I get that this year which wasn't
warranted what they did show though I
mean I'm obviously Fallout V are doing
VR look amazing doing the are is
probably gonna make people puke but
that's okay but that's what it's for
that's not got we got royalty to chat
y'all we got we got a little solid Rev
in the chat what's going on what's wrong
with you guys let's talk about that
Wolfenstein and I give away hold on get
man I'm getting out that expose me the
coffin step yes ben Stein that
Wolfenstein is my ass I love Wolfenstein
so I'm getting to oh I was excited
obviously on Skyrim switch is looking
very good with although all the Nintendo
isms and the Zelda stuff in it that's
very cool we knew that was coming we
were a little scared outdoors with our
yards or not but for me I've never
played Skyrim I'm gonna play it on the
go that's all one pool that's how I'll
come soon although and then we get
didn't get to the big two you talk about
evil within to Wolfenstein Colossus
what if the first evil within was a
throwback to original type of a res evil
um it was a little wonky but it was very
scary news excellent game and in
Wolfenstein man what they what they done
with the new order and the old blood are
to go back and the new Colossus looks
amazing absolutely amazing me those two
could have been at a Microsoft or Sony
president yes I feel you I feel you and
yeah I've been not to cut your song if
you don't know I'll jump in yeah mmm
yeah I mean I think more Kingsman a good
point because it's like I'll be honest
yeah it was probably not one of my
favorite conferences but that's the one
only for the simple fact that I don't I
didn't like the tasting like I felt like
they started off with DLC they started
off from ER with VR distraught no vo
it's kind of hard to demonstrate in any
conference we already know even if it's
the most amazing thing right and it's
like you starting off with DLC you know
and don't get me wrong you know I'm
switching to the core but at the same
time it's like you know that could have
been better suited to just having it on
yo stage so I swam with Lord King on
that as far as the heavy hit is of
course you know both styles was letting
stuff like that but I'm just I think
what it is but doesn't set the bar so
high for past III and I feel like you
know that fallout 4 debut on their stage
and stuff like that I think they had
like just a plethora of titles so the
whole thing now is that I don't think
they had necessarily the volume and they
try to do it with the whole motif with
the amusement park and stuff and four
shots Italy actually went to it cuz I
heard that it was amazing like it was
late it was fun you know me and Lord
King you know and adequate last year and
pathetic if you've never been a three
they throw it we tell you right now you
better go to Bethesda Prescott they
throw m-rated [ __ ] right they throw a
party baby
they to a party you get the jug at abia
hain you know eldest called me me and
Lord King we did the turkey legs look
like brontosaurus me means like it was
it was crazy so as far as their actual
shoulder for conference I gotta agree
with the lords like I was just kind of
Snow's worthy for me too much DLC one or
two titles that maybe I'm interested
I don't feel they had enough to warrant
a show and you know hopefully you know I
don't know if there's gonna discourage
them from doing it again because I think
a lot of these guys don't want to pay
the absorbent prices 43 boots and I
think that's what's happening right now
and they just hate like we showed they
could have just put out YouTube trailers
and we got the same thing oh you know
something I'm not not not to cut you but
I think they just do it for the
after-party
now with these guys they hit they hear
people talking hear anybody saying yo
you had the best party and to have the
same exact impact across the board from
last year to have the same yo you had
the best party this year I think they
just let it for the parties what they
need to do is just stop the conference's
and just make parties they good at they
good at those festivities yeah man open
it up the more people you can indulge
yourself to your heart's content at the
Bethesda conference those who don't know
where we gonna move what I'll be the
battery of the Lords of video don't that
yeah no doubt yourself I mean oh I
forgot my ranking yeah it was probably
see you know I it was not nothing
knocking it was something I could have
missed but you put it actually no
business didn't know what I slept yo so
anyway we'll move right on and all next
up to bat we got e a and obviously they
had a big angel look we can all agree
that they tried that they're showing was
completely forgettable trash and we can
move on to Ubisoft correct you know this
this is gonna break ins out let's just
give out break it up let them bring it
up you do your breakers up so all of us
set it off at you oh sorry because I'm
unfortunately lost Arvind did not get a
chance to access that EA play event so I
wanted to know what he felt about the
conference uh what was show actually I
went to a play afterwards after the
craziness I went a day later I went I I
didn't get to see NAS and all that hot
stuff but I was in there took a picture
with the Titan and all that stuff so I
was never a Gege oh um honestly in terms
of the car airplay was cool
it was cool the fact that they did that
you know for people and let people play
on the battlefront lines were crazy as
always and the FIFA lines and stuff like
that so it's good that they had an event
separate from the actual convention so
people can get more chances to play it
as we know it was very difficult to play
battlefront at at the convention um in
terms of the press conference again it
was just kind of weird like the Madden
drummers in the beginning like who's to
say what's going on here the feeling
that when the Patriot come she wasn't
about that yeah just give me info I
don't need all this poppin second a Tom
Brady and the Patriots I mean again at
the conference another one that to me
didn't need to exist necessarily I get I
get that battlefront was a huge game and
the fact that they showed that they
showed additional stuff to what-what was
showing it like Sony's conference or
whatnot I get that that he showed more
and it but they already had their own
event separately so honestly they could
have gotten away with showing certain
stuff at Sony's on board Sony's and not
necessarily doing their own thing I will
say that that battle frontline was real
you know who's that underneath it was
like Zelda in we it was it was long you
had to make reservations and it was
still a problem
like Zelda Lasher yeah but apart from
that I mean the the coolest stuff that I
saw the apart from the battlefront was
that that co-op jail escape game way out
and looked at Luke Harry
mm-hmm that looked very cool but again
that looked like something that could
have been on Sony staged a Microsoft
stage
um again FIFA huge the fact that uh you
know FIFA across the board is now kind
of a Sony marketed thing um the features
which the FIFA force which um yo look to
me like a play to me long and looked
amazing like and I'm not a soccer guy um
and then I made you go over this nah but
I was like you're lost [ __ ]
and that's what the switch does the
switch sort of if it forces you to take
a second look at everything like you
know what it's portable let me give it a
shot
let me see what it is mom he's about me
not really original the neatest you look
great too the need for speed look looked
amazing like a return of film when it
taken on that faster the Furious formula
also I think it's a perfect niche for it
when you look at like horizon ah and for
the horizon then you look at you know
true Forza in terms of 407 I think it
finds that perfect middle ground and it
look really good
I saw it running on an on an x1 X and it
looked really good oh and that's pretty
much it me live trying to make another
comeback we all kind of know what that
is oh-ho-ho mm-hmm it looks good and
there's not much else to say about I'll
give you my take on a society touched it
oh that hate huh no but once but once
again I don't think enough enough
content to warrant their own so this is
my number five ranked 2 out of 6 e my
number 5 Jesus all right so Lily a for
you all right a Lord addict where you at
with ei uh damn oh yes it was a
straight-up trash every game they showed
us trash the way that was the only
decent game they showed besides
battlefront and Need for Speed like
though I mean I'm not a sports guy so EA
pretty much every year's trash to me
afraid while I just feel like you know
they got so many talented developers and
they spend literally have to show every
year talking about their sports and I
felt like I feel like their sports can
get its own stream like they don't have
to wait III taught like it's not like
people are really you know gotten to the
point where most people a lot of people
have gotten to the point where they wait
for it to go to the vault so just do its
own stream and focus on your core titles
to build up your brain I feel like
Ubisoft outshine EEA the past couple
years he's we gonna get in it will be
easy but let me ask you this all that
alright
so Battlefront nor Need for Speed moved
you in any kind of way
well I said besides battlefront need for
speed all right so let's talk about pops
tool would give me give me a breakdown
on those two Need for Speed was
interesting it was more you know kid
smooth went at me because I said I was
probably gonna pick up Need for Speed
day one and he's like so you'll pick up
a need for speed without a Forza horizon
and I was like yeah kinda different
games dude if been game yeah that's your
lane that seems to be your lane and a
Battlefront did it did you get a chance
to touch did you watch oh I uh I watched
someone play they got to do a lot
because I felt like the first one they
were all people they legitly went up to
people at banks and just said give me
your money you know they use that they
use that name Star Wars and then took an
inch and ran and ran two football fields
mmm okay so - I mean right now like but
what for what you see and obviously
we've all been a little burned by the
Battlefront first one pot one but from
what you see like you felt like okay
this got promised though as far as a
battlefront - Oh better front - looks
good from what I played of it but like I
just you know when you compare it to the
first one obviously they had they had to
improve on every aspect to that game -
made it and what's worse is the first
battlefront doesn't even touch in terms
of content that it spread its two
predecessors have and that's what made
it worse it's like you gave us literally
like 10% of the content that its
predecessors had and you want like a
hundred and fifty dollars for the full
experience
oh gosh no doubt no doubt so that's what
we got from little Lord Act Lord cannot
even sitting haha 900 they under you
have a lot to say I saw you roaming a
random ei boots and just with certain
other podcasters shut up his food a half
kiss move off you listening
yes I'm talking about your thoughts of a
cop all right
so imma give EA cuz I gotta give a as a
whole I'm gonna give them as they EA
play and I'm gonna give them as the EA
conference right so the EA conference
again my feeling on software companies
having their own conference it's not
viable it's not necessary
put it out in a Nintendo Direct type of
thing and let anybody consume it however
they want to consume it because again
you're wasting people time is not
necessary
alright um to their games their games
were out of all the software companies
the most outstanding uh you have the
FIFA fight for however you want to call
it a soccer football that is number one
across the world and it was in great
form it looked fantastic it looked
amazing and it played amazing so you
have those combinations and for some
weird reason I don't know how they did
it
somebody say oh let's put it on a switch
and it got it to the switch looking and
playing amazing so yes yes from a
technical aspect those developers need a
hand clap because I really didn't think
that that was going to get logged
kidding when our system hire they will
be able to pull off a full version of
that fie huh yeah I thought was gonna be
fight for go rihanna yeah I brought yeah
you didn't fight with any girl I said
Lord Lord Marlyn yes over there said
Lord Kai by two over there I see yo
check this I know y'all don't mess with
me fight for me check it out
and their faces explored kibosh member
loss are we we we couldn't get him away
we went to play we went to play arms or
something else and he was they're not
paying us any mind oh yeah the game face
it this man plays no soccer but gaylord
kick that yeah it was amazing
alright so then you know you go over to
and I was the least okay the the free
for the FIFO was the least and I'm gonna
I'm going up from the least to the best
then I went and I played the Madden Oh F
Madden is the thing that this every year
type of thing
don't understand they can just send out
a patch and update but they want to
gouge you for your pockets because they
understand that you're a fool this year
is on the Frostbite engine frostbite
engine again looks amazing plays amazing
pop as a Polish and a finish to it that
it didn't have our previous years the
control on the characters feel spot-on
a little hick collision they have to fix
that and they explained to us that what
we was playing with a pre-alpha bill so
um that stuff should be rectified before
the game releases again Madden a plus
beautiful game on to the life the life
like in past live years you had some
wonky graphics or you had some wonky
play mechanics and it just never meshed
I think last year they got closest but
not right that you already know was
subpar to the 2k this year in playing
that game is indistinguishable from the
2k from the standpoint that the
playability and graphics meet at that
same apex and it makes it a viable
option to purchase this year price point
is key yes if they want to do what they
and they have the chance this year to do
what 2k did to them
2k had a - a $20 price line that force
gamers to stop looking at live and stop
looking at Madden and look over at this
$20 game to give it a chance to grab the
the my share of the of the public and
once they did that that's how they
became the juggernaut they was they are
and they were able to raise the price of
sequential years after that it just kept
going kept going kept going so I think
that the price point is key I think a
$29.99 price point for set game is very
viable put it inside EA access so people
can get a chance to touch it I'm buying
a game day one what happened what it is
is when I play the demo I'm gonna beat
the breaks off of dicks move now I'm
gonna go ahead go ahead and state this a
bit okay so you know
smooth and you know lurking got into a
game of life and get smooth again is
like uh the Kovalev of this he has been
gypped and I'm the Hun tree water this
and I just give straight knockouts oh
[ __ ] so he got heated he doesn't know me
in a sense of game playing if you listen
to all the lords all the Lords will tell
you that be careful for the mind games
that Lord King plays Lord King will make
you believe me his greatest friend his
ally his comrade and at the end of the
match when you've lost and you thought
you and your friend had a good game
that's when the demons come out that's
sure kids smooth found out the hard way
of how king tactics work and then he
further entrenched himself in King
tactics by making a deal that he will
buy me the hundred and whatever again
you know II a dude $150 busts off so I
want the hundred and fifty dollar game I
have to beat him in one quarter one
quarter this is how [ __ ] or ignorant
the bet is he didn't stay beat him in a
quarter by leading by score he said beat
him in a quarter by points so that means
he could be blowing me out in any
quarter and I beat him
22:19 in any quarter and he has to buy
me the game a fool is bigger than on
Larry's Harry's video footages up on
Twitter Instagram Facebook atop and um
if you need that footage I will shoot
that to you directly
um it is something that is worthy of
your viewing pleasure uh-huh and then
from there I'm going to The Sims 4
Sims 4 beautiful game uh the reason why
it's higher than the live the live you
went in with question marks and Sims 4
reaches more people uh the masses
actually liked that stuff and the
portability of everything is a good game
it's a very good game very well
thought-out and they fixed a couple of
things I have
problems with as far as that goes then
on to the need for speed
like Lord addict said day one purchase
it is fast and furious
literally fast and furious cinematics
the whole bit yeah beautiful beautiful
60 frames per second 1080p moving it was
hitting all the bells and whistles and
it was doing it like a burnout a mixed
with a need for speed it was incredible
it's an incredible game like Lord addict
says they have great developers over
there and they have a twirling in the
corner churning out sports games every
year um and then battlefront battlefront
is my number one game from EA yeah uh
because I I wasn't up on battlefront the
first one it sucks so bad it was garbage
it was totally trash it had promised but
in an end still trash hmm this one the
Polish was there
the massive you felt the scale of a war
it was there like and then the way you
summon your heroes beautifully done I
would not think about that because that
small village prevented me from playing
it oh yeah yeah
Billy John the one trying to play you
yeah I got a chance to play and I got a
chance to play it in the PC section um
yeah I'll get into that later so overall
I give ba a c-plus oh right so you up
from a see if the reason why it gets the
C+ is because really their games were so
stellar yeah and they get a plus because
of e a plug I play that's it that's the
only reason why the Plus showed up
otherwise yeah above what company and
they don't need to be having their own
conference yet again do they get a plus
because you know you bet the win this is
live for free don't lie the lowest move
of it because for those that don't know
about this bet I think I was actually
badly looking because I wish you'd post
that that lob that you put with him when
we all that dinner and you got
ready to bet it was one of the
[ __ ] okay it wasn't loud but I
wish it like Twitter can see it because
okay Twitter followers would have loved
to see the interaction you guys pop that
into each other play it love
it wasn't elastic and the speculations
to the bed kept changing throughout the
media oh yeah just the price of love
alone Oh watch it too what do I get if I
beat Yuki you don't get shaken up the
King trap baby the King trap would it
look to this side you get my that's
right that's all I gave it I mean again
the Lord's on fire with this Oh first I
wanna shout out to see Oh Andrew Wilson
got a chance to chop it up with him I
got a name drop a little date um yeah he
was really cool and um ours the event
the event itself the e play event I felt
was very cool you know the way they had
to set up you know the kind of live band
and stuff like that you know I think was
interactive I did prefer last year's ei
play honestly though they set up in the
building we play title falls a little
better than this open set up and you
know I got a shout out in front of those
guys out all the guys that couldn't get
in like that sucked
like a lot easy I mean they really have
to plan a little bit better as far as
that whole thing is concerned because
there were ton of people who did the
pre-registration and still wasn't able
to get in and they got to work on that
you know but I the event itself I was
caught it now as far as the conference
itself almost was theirs yeah thanks
Thomas what game so it doesn't have the
negative effect that it has on a lot of
you guys so for me I'm expecting now I
know the new man's coming I want to see
what's going on man they look good
engine look cool whatever you know I was
more excited or response r45 or switch
obviously when five was announced I
needed to know what that was looking
like Mike Lord King said I need to know
if that was a fight for go /
mini-version pleasantly surprised full
commentary you know I'm gonna say was
probably moving at 30 as opposed to 60
but it looked good it looked good
animations were great I was getting to
it and Dom yeah need for speed
definitely that cinematic faster furious
kind of feel probably
game I'm gonna pick up but um I still
understand the audience it reaches and
it was really you know really cool
looking as far as the battlefront to
like what Alex said you know a small
village in front of everybody you know
play that game was just - I just say you
know I'm going to give up I'm gonna wait
see if I'm catch on it on the floor on
battlefront it looked amazing it looked
amazing look like you know they got a
story this year hopefully you know it
looks like they address an interesting
story yeah yeah every definitely
interest cuz they go from the what a
glowing look they go from now what is it
the rebel perspective only they're going
from the rebel perspective of a
commander that uh after the death star
blows up you plays a FEMA so you know
you know there are people that go play
because of a female like big bad shots
that me said rude well yeah I mean I get
it I get it so the whole thing is you
know I just I felt it was solid again
like Lord King said was it enough to
warrant an entire conference probably
not um la I will say this though live
was a positive step you know obviously I
am NOT in beloved I'm more of a 2k guy
used to be alive got back in the day so
the sea life fall on such hard times the
past four or five years is kind of
painful to see because actually walking
out with veterans of live we know and
love was in its glory right we know when
live was that place you know to go to
play basketball and just to see them
constantly getting beat the brakes off
by 2k it's kind of disheartened so to
have them come back with a new engine
you know it looks solid the premise is
dead the foundation is there let's just
see if they upkeep it I think more King
is on the money I think the price point
is key if you want to get back in the
game you may have to take the short term
out and priced at it like forty dollars
or something you know and and just
getting back in the game to know that
okay we're here you know I'm saying that
kind of thing so um you know overall
again another see you know nothing
outside of battle from my stand out
nothing like crazy crazy to make me go
oh my god you got to do this again next
year got a bit so that's what I get for
a II a
and we are gonna move on we have the
left the last of the three nine big
three which is Ubisoft and they had a
conference this year y'all so I want to
get this set off with los sovereign
because I always felt like Lord Salman
is a very Ubisoft kind of guy I don't
know I always get this feeling from him
sometimes so Lord sovereign Ubisoft
they're up to bat impression what you
feel yeah you're not wrong about that I
gravitate to the UB games I'm a big
Assassin's Creed crack head and the Far
Cry game so um honestly yeah I think
again in terms of ranking they were my
number four um I thought they had a lot
of great content um some cool announces
I thought the Miyamoto would Guillermo
on the stage is cool those are the weird
and awkward but it was a walk a little
awkward layout area especially leather
goods yeah absolutely it was just a
little weird but you know it was cool to
see them on stage together and Mario
rabbits that came that everyone was
worried about turns out to be something
that everyone is excited about and we're
getting it very soon so so that was cool
um again a return to form for samson's
Creed Assassin's Creed I'm not I'm not
dude in every single Saxons creed that
gets every collectible that cleans the
map um unfortunately to do it with which
syndicate which is kind of a crime
because syndicate is considerably better
gaming than unity but I will get to that
but Assassin's Creed um origins just
absolutely fixes everything that was
wrong with the series and as all these
RPG like elements loot elements um stats
and stuff that people look for these
type of open-world games
I think it's going to be a runaway hit
this year so I was very pleased with
that
um the the crew - looks good I guess we
recently got the crew of free on Xbox on
what you would call it a games a gold uh
maybe a month or two ago so I haven't
really played it I thought the premise
was cool I didn't get downloaded I
compared data
oh yeah anyway keen kids talking [ __ ]
about you in that comment section just
yeah Emily oh my god video footage don't
let me release that
don't ever leave that footage to the
streets and let's talk you are you I
suggest you take stop doing the Koval
off be awesome is sit down and be hung
looking looking at as a james comey foot
and footage them don't let me get you a
peach were do you could do all right so
the crew yeah things like they improve
upon that all that premise I'm what I'd
be interesting to see what that is South
Park obviously everybody's excited for
and hopefully it will come out this year
as they said um skullenbones again
taking that taking that uh that
Assassin's Creed Black Flag premise of
the sailing and kind of blowing that out
I'm interested to see if there's more
game than just that because I I'm not
quite sure if that will hold up as a
game on its own over the long term it's
pretty though and I'm sure they polished
it um but then I get off me well you
know again I interesting to see what
what that game turns into um Far Cry 5
look great Ram beautifully eye on the
snow floor I saw that you B's booth and
it was running on a pro it was a little
hitching but I'll be playing it on an X
so I'm I'm good I'm sure that'll be
cleaned up a little bit oh and then for
me honestly apart from the Assassin's
Creed um the fact that they finally came
out with Beyond Good and Evil it was
like you know I would wait to get to
this part yeah the fact that they you
know after all this time they come out
to make this emotional announcement and
it's really it's trying to live up to
the hype of a game that's been kind of
up in the ether for for a decade or more
I mean so the fact that they're taking
the time to try to make that a reality
in his special um they had just enough
for me to warn that our press conference
just enough of gradually with the
Rabbids and and whatnot um yeah but I
think they need and my number four name
off those previews of those rankings
early
don't give us the letter it's a little
I'm so good
well let it what letter you go A to D I
will give you this I've seen it uh B -
Wow okay and we'll get into this later
but for me again III means showing me
something I'm not expecting I'm not I'm
not going halfway across the country to
be regurgitated stuff like that doesn't
I don't want ad kid kids loosing a key
David is that is the first quarter go
keep the Lord doesn't like well that's
all I need is one quarter don't forgive
me but what is the great second quarter
player of all time fat oh my god I am
pig Bobby bet is going bid a big if rep
bra lucky oh you got you said you
chopping at the bit is fun yes yes
yo they had the most awkward dumb sure
level that was really but that's
everyone every year we don't know that
was the worst awkward show with these
French vampires
that was the show ever they highlight
was my Amato running out of the back and
that interaction between those two guys
you have one guy that was generally
excited to be there the other guy
couldn't match the other dudes
enthusiasm he just came off as awkward
and foolish as possible he was the worst
announcer they should just keep him in
the back don't do it to stay awake that
was the worst show the worst Joe by far
they get a F they get asked to get
straight to you there was the worst
abuse awkward let me tell you why and
you want to say here you go say wow this
guy really thought about that
listen talk to me Nintendo made that
game Nintendo made that game yesterday
channel game sir
let me let me tell you something that
they gave the rights over they
definitely gave the right solo and we
would actually surprised by Nintendo
actually allowing edge right let me let
me let me go make it I mean let me go in
let me go in I know they had they
developers over there okay it is nice
that game looks straight up like it was
made on the Wii U was made for the wheel
you could tell it was in development for
a while it looked like Mario 3d Land
that's exactly what it looks like um
with a cover based system beautiful I'm
not saying that that game sucks oh it
didn't need to be there it wasn't on the
show remember the word that I use is
awkward because that is going to be
prevalent throughout this whole thing
now you go to the next games and the
next games are awkward as well that net
that black flag skullenbones crap you
saw you see a thieves and said yo you we
gonna make a realistic jump oh we
already have the water engine you have a
mechanic from a game that was kind of a
failed game in my viewers black flag you
took what you throw in the fetch Ashi
bag of that game and you try to wrap a
whole game around it it wasn't
interesting it wasn't fantastic
it was choppy yeah the NPC's was walking
around with no true interaction it
looked like black flag light and if
anyone else at Dan said oh this game is
gonna go up against CFDs well you have
total control over everything and this
game looks like you have absolutely zero
control I don't care for that game if I
want to play Oh what is that what's that
game that we used to play beam no
ambition um and we used to sit there's a
board game with the ships um then you
hold my battleship battle state
battleship Johnny if I want to play
battleship I got it in my closet made it
and I don't need it I don't we do much
good at doing good let me ask you in
reference to that specific game now are
seeing in the Twitter streets when that
came out these Twitter streets were like
nobody's around to see a D nobody touch
it they were saying that this is look
how better it looked look eyes the way
supposed to be done so you feel
that see if these have nothing to worry
about no if nothing at all they say
those are graphic [ __ ] they didn't
like the art direction of SIA tapes
nothing at all the water and see it
thieves
smacks their whole game doesn't make any
sense
all right a Fiat thieves is a goal
anywhere do anything social mmm oh okay
yeah I don't I don't think this game is
that it's not comparing a tree in that
regard another thing what do you got
thinking is yeah I don't think it's a
nothing is just gonna be shipped combat
it's not gonna go this they really
didn't say anything else so that's what
it came off as honestly I wouldn't be
took they took the ship combat to be
completely honest with you it look like
a multiplayer on the game
yes that's it and it looked like you go
from point A to point B in missions
excuse me and trying to destroy the next
teams are battleships guard that's what
if you office I mean other Kirby to but
that's what it came off as ghosts on
what week based on what we see in the
trailer guy looking yeah just just you
know sit these hands down stomps that
game don't need to do when you get water
physics right to match the thieves water
physics and you show me somebody jumping
off that ship and swimming down at the
bottom and then going to the other guy
snippin causing hell over there when you
start causing hell in another dude ship
I lack the boy is go then get your boats
out of the water color doors and build
your game back in the closet this is
garbage in this trash and if I want to
play that game mark the game back left
yo for real if I want to play that game
I got black flag right now I just go
play it and carpet all right going to my
game so that in words that your game
here yeah you know what after the
crumpled em it hits my it gets my crap
emoji wow that game alone definitely did
not need to show up their names talking
strong I'm like oh hey do you know this
show was awkward when I had to resort to
cousin disgusting show what was that -
that was when they got to Far Cry 5 the
fourth floor [ __ ] I got not that get
everybody was sleeping at that point and
he had to resort to cussing to wake
everybody up and that's when you know
the downward spiral into the abyss was
going down all right so my game of the
show I know I'm a breaking a little
barrier everybody knows my game it shows
Assassin's Creed and Assassin's Creed
couldn't be shown in his proper form
because Microsoft already had poached
the game they said that you can say
something about the game but you cannot
show actual gameplay that we are showing
so they resorted to again this word
awkward a cutscene to three people
sitting in front of a TV that they could
show it off the TV it was awkward
disgusting and busted it was just busted
and they had to develop up then you can
show he had pride in his game and he
wanted to present his game what they
should've did was allowed him to go on a
Microsoft stage and talk about his game
there again software companies should
not be doing this because the waters
down everybody show totally disgusting
for a game that is game of the year so
if you only saw it in that one format
please watch Microsoft's show so you can
actually see his game and it's all's
glory um next I'm an end on a high note
guys I'm an actor I know the next game
the far cry 5 are me on the that game
talked looks really good at you
it was far cry we know for guys gonna
look good we know for cries gonna play
good and being a far cry 4 and for cry 3
started off with beautiful story we know
that this story is gonna be engaging and
it's going to push boundaries okay we
know that so that's not something that
is far-fetched again that game could be
showed on Sony's or Microsoft stage and
it would had the same exact effect
besides the cursing so the guy was
probably upset that Sony nor Microsoft
wanted to pony up to put that game on
their show stage so he came on he had
his curse to wake everybody up here you
want to
I gotta wake everybody up like everybody
would know everybody was strong in a
show if you get to that point everybody
was sleeping he cursed he said yeah I
got the reaction no no no you didn't get
the reaction you got the D reaction
because a lot of people's like I thought
oh man come on man you didn't have to
resort to that not necessary then you
saw why it was necessary because he was
setting you up for the most epic fail in
videogame history is is this beyond good
and bad - Oh feeling it God okay I'm not
a fan of no game play so brothers strap
in because that had zero game 0 they sat
there for 20 years and made a trailer
that had no none of the original
characters a sufferer at the end and you
don't even know if that's her you didn't
know what you were watching why this
monkeys cursing and he's looking like
the Bionic Commando doob which I feel is
absolutely 100% racist because if the
Bionic Commando rule is look like dude
with the dreads why is the monkey
looking like the Bionic Commando do
disrespectful waste this game can you
got off with the drain head it was
garbage it was the best CGI trailer I
ever seen it was cursed and all through
it so I can't show my kids it had no
gameplay and they ended it it was like
we did it and the game is coming out
then the awkwardness got to this apex
bro not even talk about that dance -
crap that doesn't even talked about it
here yanked him up when they got on
stage and it was like I would like to
take everybody like a war show I like to
thank everybody for showing up and these
wonderful hotel business we all are here
we all up and the vampires all came out
was with me all agencies wipe the tears
from his eyes you saw the CGI trailer
know anything anything I'm giving y'all
all monkey catches and I want you to
give us input and
to make this game because you guys other
I swear that game is going to fail
miserably the first game was mediocre at
best they had a cult following and you
did not the last chiller that they show
that I think was like a Nintendo
something and then they actually show
something that was looking like it was
gonna be game there the king of trailers
they have miss miss been misleading you
guys for forever and it will continue to
mislead you guys and you're falling to
the rabbit hole talking about big
casting
it was flash utter garbage and I don't
ever want to see their games I want to
ever see them have a conference just
didn't get a license or clue so Chicago
no let's get outta here with that just
put up a games with everybody else
now what was that debt rating the
reserves so that we go we gotta here Wow
okay alright uh looking let us know how
you feel
I think is more addict oh I actually had
a completely different but you like the
last cuz you like the rabbits take the
round atop the show I thought that I
thought that all right obviously we know
Assassin's Creed we'll get into
Microsoft later but on money you know to
me ah anything with Egyptian culture you
know is just something that's gonna
stand out to me like so I just I felt
they went back to its roots I thought it
was just thought it was action packed
I thought the ethnicity was correct of
st. Agnes yes I was I was afraid if they
were gonna go there and obviously you
know when I won't get too political but
um so that was dead the rabbits was huge
I mean just was in fact but yeah I hear
what you're gonna look at and nothing is
like their conference had awkward
moments cringe-worthy moments of
interaction between host and audience
yes where I disagree with you is if you
just look at them on the merits of
content shown of course fantastic you
know because from
Muriel rabbiting to me that was huge
because I'm like okay Wow grandpa
Nintendo is giving the Rings the key to
their car mMmmm come on that's unheard
of me and Laura adequate talking about
we were like wow this represents our new
Nintendo and it's no I'm an ex calm
phonetic I'm playing X club - right now
my backlog by the way and on just to
have that in portable form with the
mariokarrion turn-based thing with
Muriel I'm they got me they won take my
money when is it coming out take my
money as far as the crew okay and I
wasn't never really a fan of the first
crew at all to me that's for Horizons
Lane and what for what they showed you
know it looked cool you know it look
decent that last game that you going in
on I'm with you know that laughs you
know the monkey know like like listen
you know I look alright and look
original I will give it that but it's a
trailer it's not gameplay Mineral King
I've been around a block way too long to
know and loss sovereign not you know
like as well he's a young GOG but we've
been around long enough to know that
okay being show no gameplay so I'm not
gonna get caught up with the the smoke
and mirrors you know same kind of aspect
of that but all the role I mean
everything I they showed I felt was
solid I never felt the kind I just felt
their execution in the message horrible
was horrible as far as the it was very
awkward that like the Mentawai Amato and
the French guy was weird when my mother
came out with the gun and it was it was
just being he cooking matches enthusiasm
like it was gonna lose a language
barrier it was
that felt like get them off the stage
out on too long yeah there was a point
there was a point where Iggy Mo actually
says take the picture take the picture
and then scoot
Hey he broke he broke the pose it was
like it was very rehearsed yeah it's
like a very rehearsed on one end not on
the other end just say yeah I go and the
way I tribute it I just laugh to myself
I just felt it was you know you got a
Japanese guy the French guy and they
clearly didn't practice this enough and
it was just awkward but overall like I
said I mean the show I felt was solid
and as far as that last foot the old
Floyd show voter they looked a little
honest I liked it the only reason why I
liked it glugging is because let's be
honest Ubisoft and Lord addict knows
what I'm about to say like Oh be soft is
the king of sometimes delivering broken
products right and we let's be honest
we've gotten those assassin Creed game
which one that was it was the unity or
you know the business issues I mean the
hacking and stuff like that as much DS
game Ubisoft makes great games but it's
like they always have some weird issue
and then the player count drops off and
it's always something with them right so
to me I felt that it was like they
little react over like it's all about
the game hahaha like live out I just got
a vibe like a vehicle apologist vibe
that we want your feedback they brought
all the people that displayed to kind of
bring like a team-building thing all
right they suckered me with that all
right I felt that was them trying to
learn that was corporate back room they
should do that in the company crap I
mean listen everybody's entitled to
their own opinion and I value
everybody's opinion on the show I'm not
saying that the content that they showed
was trash they had very good games that
would stand out games that could be
enough shown on like I said what every
software company could have been showing
on everybody else's show absolutely and
that goes to the main argument which is
what we would continue to punches that's
you know these third parties don't
necessarily need to have that because
like you said it pulls well it pulls
Assassin's Creed away from what you
wrote you know opposed Mario away from
Nintendo you know it posed
things away and I hear you mean then you
know as we even forgot to mention as far
as the ei with the anthem I want to get
back on that road they had to dad to
tease it mm and then be like wait for
Marcus off stage so it just took the
thunder of it's over I'm with you on
conferences doing that but oh I'm gonna
surprise the Lord I gave it I gave it
about a BB - I'm gonna lock into it I'm
a lock into Abby okay I'm gonna I
actually did like it and um you know I
felt this is Ubisoft turning a corner
but Lord addict I'm very curious about
your ranking and your impressions of
loose I actually liked it - there's
right Lord let's go go also good with
the you know they opened it pretty
decent I felt like you know the Pacey
wasn't the best but it wasn't the worst
at all I felt like they showed for the
most part solid games you know for when
it comes to conferences I try not to
rank them too much on who's hosting but
that you know I don't think we're gonna
go in - you know I felt like every host
needs to be that PC dude show first
shout-out to the PC gaming schlissel oh
let's let's give them their own thing
let's let's give my own will give killer
cuz they deserve they really deserve
this yeah whatever we gotta get his name
I would love to get him on a show he is
the most amazing host law graduate I
don't like that in any video game format
I don't know he's got multiple jobs
that's how you do a show I'm gonna get
his name but whoever to watch the PC
gaming show if you're in the chat please
type what that guy's name is cuz I
definitely want to follow him and give
him a salute again like back to you but
you know this shows solid games and you
know obviously when the crew showed up I
fell asleep in you know there's certain
games that they launched that you know
out of all the third parties I felt like
they had the best by far because eh
master the show talk about nonsense but
does it didn't even really show up they
showed up halfway they spent more money
on the after part and they did their
conference
and I felt like Ubisoft was only people
that showed up and was they look we got
games like if you don't remember Ubisoft
the Ubisoft conference were the Ubisoft
area a e3 was packed at all time was a
get where these idiots on the stage
dancing yeah that's all I was you wanted
to see how foolish they can make this up
look there was Hawaii looking if we go
if we could if we gonna rank it will
lose that III on the floor right now on
the floor you know buddy I'm not going
for me I'm not going for it listen I
can't I have to say date conference
content they had very decent content
that could have been on other guys stuff
now I'm gonna look at it as a whole I'm
looking at it as like you said well we
have to put the pace on the side notice
the conference you give them a pass no
they're not no they're not in the past
and then you water down your best IP
because you you bid it it and sold it
out to the highest bidder and now you
couldn't even show it on yourself so
remember they show stands for
awkwardness from the beginning to the
end it was just other awkward
cringe-worthy stuff that didn't need to
be done or somebody didn't oversee this
here there's nothing that you know we're
Hearst properly or something I don't
know
I'll give anything like look at it no
the funny thing is that I got that's
kind of what they're known for in terms
of if there's any conference over the
past five six years that you know is
known for its cringe-worthy moments and
it's almost expected now is Ubisoft
discussed that's not let's not forget
mister caffeine you hit already it all
right yeah honestly they're the only
ones I saw to give it past you because I
am so morbidly curious to what they're
gonna do yeah you looking at him and
saying what these people gonna do next
I don't want your money with my company
I don't think I need to tune in to see
how horribly bad you're gonna be I think
most you're almost lean into it they
almost lean into it and I think moving
forward they probably will lean into it
even more like they just want it just
happens every year especially with when
it comes down to a Ubisoft us something
that other Kong other companies don't
normally do yearly they launch new IPs
almost year yes yes this is true you
gotta we gotta give them credit
excellent I mean they they glowed so
what was what what your ranking will be
lordotic I gotta have to give them a B
okay so they're the best of the worse
for you guys and that's fantastic so
with my F that brings them back to a
seat love everything the love everything
grounded them into the sea territory
where everybody is something to see
Tennyson Metacritic standards there we
go baby we gotta use a guy use any
weekend Lord a turkey does anything else
you wanted to say it original I know we
gotta talk to you no not really
when it comes to Ubisoft you know they
did I feel like they went out there and
you know it's not like they go out there
and you know they promise [ __ ] they
don't deliver for the most part all
their new IPs do really well most
sometimes Ubisoft shows up and screws up
their game like for honored but you know
for the most part what Ubisoft shows out
there it's critically acclaimed sells
well in you know I can't I can't knock
them on that so yeah cool so we have
finished the concluded that third-party
companies and now we go to get into the
big three it's so wait a second we
didn't do the PC oh you know what
looking you are correct yeah before we
even do that before we get into the
victory let us go with the pc cohn let
me let me set that off the honorable
mention is honorable mention because you
know what this was my first PC
conference never like yeah like I didn't
even watch that [ __ ] the past couple of
years they did it yeah to be honest I
you know as most Lords know and to the
you know to the audience you know I'm
not a PC gamer console is my preference
it's just that's the way I'm wired No
respect to the you know master race and
any form I know you guys are out there
with your rigs doing it hard so you know
when I was invited it was honor you know
and um to go and experience it and I was
just like now her that pass show was not
good
let's get that I was gonna get caviar
last year this show was lit you know
again if anybody in a chat knows who the
book the host of the PC game is better
than all the third parties but he he was
engaging he was funny he first you are
talking about he was not a corporate
shill he actually played these games and
you can tell the passion show loved it
so as far as what was shown you know
there was a lot of you know number one
highlight let's get it out the way
ex-con fanboys in the building when the
XCOM 2 was announced the DLC you know
expansion pack I lost my mind I felt
there were a lot of cool game shown it
was a switch game that almost looked
like a um it was almost like a call but
like a cross between arm which call it
advance wars and it has has this 2d art
so Lord whisky knows what I'm talking
about cuz we were going crazy on that
you know Age of Empires on the show was
debut you know honestly felt that the PC
show actually went in depth and I don't
want to touch too much in the Microsoft
but they went in depth with Microsoft
titles a little bit better than
Microsoft themselves did it was a game
that last night I finally got an idea of
what that was it looked really cool 4 to
7 breaking down the features and stuff
like that you know I mean it really to
me was well done there was also one more
stand down ain't trying to get the name
off the top of my tongue ok the shadow
war also on that stage as well um PC
show was lit it was very solid you know
and um like I said like look at my I
might have to include this in the
rotation shout out the Lord swag cuz I
know his PC came and said it to the
cause well but you guys did good I was
very impressed overall ranking strong B
I mean I was thoroughly impressed with
the PC gaming show and I did not expect
that so that's what I gotten anybody
else to jump in on B - I don't have
nothing to say just the B - B
I lost love looking yeah I mean for me
like the fact that they're bringing back
Age of Empires at the finish moving into
position that's that's huge that's
amazing um you know all this stuff with
Battletech and getting some
single-player stuff um the additions and
making the pub G that all this is coming
to the to the Xbox version also um and
for me something a it's probably low Oh
cliffy B cliffy B on the stage talking
up and that is but saying the truth
saying the truth so um it was good to
see him on stage and for me my little
low-down thing clay entertainment for me
created one of the best stealth games
ever in mark of the ninja and and their
little RPG coming out now Griff Lance
has me very excited because I just again
I'm not a big don't starve person in
terms of the survival gaming genre but
that mark of the ninja is one of my top
games of all time so I'm interested to
see what Griff lands is about and yeah
yeah again it was very solid and moved
it moved briskly on the hosters was
amazing at that and moving and moving
the show along um and again all the geek
stuff with uh in terms of Nvidia and the
Intel stuff with the new processors um
yeah man they for people who love this
stuff they really they hit it out of the
park nice Lord King Lord King is uh yeah
he's so overwhelmed and songs of peace
no no it was long and he had winning it
out just then um okay the PC show man
this is my first PC show uh I was um
thrown aback by the movie theater that
they all delays in him I guess a venue
was B's venue was amazing
um the the aesthetics of the place set
it up very nicely
the crowd was very engaged with the host
the host was the best holes out of any
show Microsoft Sony Nintendo anybody
show he was the best holes he's how you
supposed to host the
keeps you engaged he he forces
interaction um it was fantastic and the
point that he made it his own even when
they fumbled words on the stage he
looked over to his his calls or whatever
developer that was there and he helped
build it and had that excitement going
and he kept you know giving you key you
can a little bit there locating because
I think he was phenomenal
arm content-wise it was the perfect
companion app to Microsoft show because
certain games like last night where I
was uh wanting to understand more and
see more of the game they went in depth
could he be standing on the stage was an
iconic moment for myself because I loved
every game that this man has ever made
and he gets it he gets one Bullock once
and he gets what the public needs I'll
play lawbreakers on PC and PlayStation 4
and I say again that this guy has the
Midas touch when it comes to making
games he is underrated developer if he's
not known as God and he's in the gaming
world he should be known as a God in the
gaming world because his hand
association to whatever title that is is
guaranteed to produce a a plus title I
feel you I just want this jumping on
your point with cliffy B for those who
don't know like cliffy B to me speaks to
the game and when he came out on that
stage like Lord King said he said one of
that you know $60 multi player only be
as taking a clear shot at overwatch
let's make let's be clear he's coming
for overwatch with that comment I love
Breck I had to shout about like and even
made another comment Lord Kaiser show
like he's even on Twitter going hand
okay he was saying like um you know and
for the I was the jet about he said oh
man it was another Pope peer-to-peer
service that peer-to-peer serving
nonsense dedicated servers like
he speaks to the gamer and it was good
to see him out there revived as
microphone a little sad that I don't
know how that relationship didn't stay
together you know I mean I know he grows
game he looks like he's a free spirit
that he's going to do it how he feels
that everybody needs it done if he if
he's a chef he's gonna prepare that food
how he would want it prepared so what
it's King Kai now oh I'm coming in and
out yeah now you back you mom said the
chef got you right at the chef the way
he would want to get them yeah like you
know he makes sure that he gives you his
product how he would want his product so
you know it's gonna be a quality product
through and through at all times um
Microsoft uh with the fourth of seven
the fact that they was able to show
fourth and seven on the PC show remember
I honestly think that his whole Windows
10 PC stuff is a boon for us when this
Xbox X comes out because the games that
are shown and the games that were played
at the PC show they went in depth and
these was a lot of Microsoft titles so
if your Microsoft fan look at the PC
show because the PC show ended with a
great IP from Microsoft which was Age of
Empires
now out of all the shows and this one
you gotta say PC is the hardware
software kind of amalgamation of the two
uh I will give that show a solid b-plus
uh because of content yes crazily
because of the host because he kept me
engaged I did not fall asleep I was
enthused with every title even if I
didn't know what the title was the
hoglets
that game that Microsoft showed and they
went in death it was beautiful it was um
what's that Harvest Moon from Nintendo
mix with uh par what's that um Oh pen
diva pinata yeah yeah yeah
for venture time it was so much mix into
one beautiful game that I didn't get to
explain it on Microsoft stage but these
guys did they take the time out for
these little indie games absolutely then
brought the devs out for ya sat down
with him really engaged him asked him a
lot of question it was it was a great
show for the gamer I got hardcore gaming
you're a fan of these games I want you
looking like there's no way you could
not have been impressed so definitely I
agree
don't be turned off because it says PC
don't be turned off because a lot of
these PC games are catering to the
console gamer because they have control
of functionalities so a lot of times you
can take your USB control or your
Bluetooth controller and you can play
these games don't be turned off by that
word PC I know it has been come a little
stigma but give it a look because I
think the PC worm has turned that it's
starting to become indistinguishable and
this is mainly because of Microsoft
between the console and the PC Gamer
we've coming to a point where soon is
all gonna be one universe and I am very
pleased at that yeah definitely man I'm
glad I'm Nessen glad we got it to shout
out the Shadow King for actually mention
me make reminding me to know that PC in
because that was a worthy mention so
we're gonna move on real quick unless
everybody's got everything to say PC and
dom we're gonna jump right into the big
three and i'm gonna set it off quick
grab grab pod did Ted though had a
direct they did not have a traditional
press conference they had a direct so
I'm also gonna start it off with Lord at
it um obviously all of us here switch
game but we want to get your impression
specifically because I know you are not
happy with the previous direct before e3
Lord at it so I need your impressions Oh
Tendo show yeah well I enjoyed for the
most part I felt like Nintendo they kind
of had the best pacing of them all like
it's amazing what they showed in 25
minutes
it's great
they show in 25 minutes they showed a
lot of you know you know people are like
all you know they only showed an inlet
of Metro for that's that [ __ ] we
needed more a mile of that's all anyone
ever needed and what kills me is like
you get people like and these are the
same people hyping up showing a forty
second trailer for The Last of Us - and
it's not coming out for three years
these are the same people that are
hyping up a thirty second trailer to
death stranding that's not coming out to
the PS five oh so uncle you know I get
where people are coming from but you
know when it comes down to it you know a
lot of Nintendo fans felt like they gave
up on that brain entirely you know
because they never talked about it I
mean look at the the Wii U we went an
entire generation about Zelda
an entire generation without Zelda mmm
so at the other day I'm glad I felt like
they showed solid games and you know
what they failed to do that what they
did that you know not necessarily you
know the competition failed to do but
for the most part they did that they
showed what's coming up this year
hello-hello and I can I have to respect
that
they show that like look like you know
we got stuff next year you know they did
do that you know uh for shout for the
future of Metroid crying for and you
know they do coming out said yo leave me
alone we're making a Pokemon game you
don't have to tweet me you don't have to
blow me up I will I am making what so
you know and I show that direct that
Pokemon direct the sour taste was Swiss
was high and there's a showed stuff like
you know the the fire emblem they show
Zeno they showed uh you know it's it's
clear that you know we're getting the
Odyssey we're getting the the Mario
rabbits
I mean that's that's a lot of first
party you know some of that you know
Game of the Year contender all in this
year
so if I have to give it I had to get
them but I have to give them a beat
okay go solve it I heard you chuckling
in the background I know you had a lot
to say about this subject about grandpa
Nintendo's direct slash press conference
but serving I need you in here
what is your feeling my feeling on this
and this is a general feeling about III
as a whole for me III at that time of
year when you want these companies to
come out and wow you and surprise you
and and make you excited for stuff that
you didn't know was coming and stuff
that's coming soon and I think more than
anyone else they got that right this
year Nintendo when and I don't care how
many years Metroid Prime for is out it's
coming and the fact that they were
willing to just put that out there that
to me is what III is about Wow me floor
me with something I haven't murder love
them all and then you support that by
telling me that all these other great
games that we may have heard something
about are coming soon
I mean I'm Xenoblade Chronicles looks
amazing it's a blast open-world deep
JRPG they released the last iteration of
it not too long ago on the on the new on
the new 3ds these are huge games the
fact that they're confident that is
coming out this year though I think it
might get pushed a little bit but I you
know the fact that they come there but
um it's it's really something special I
think they hit it out of the park man
and then you talk about arms came out
this past Friday had it haven't had a
chance to touch it but we already know
we're in love with it splatoon next
month Fire Emblem a proper fire amble
Mario Radleys one of the stuff that's
coming out soon
um room it's just an and marrow Odyssey
what what can you say about maryada CD
they really they went back to that
formula that people waiting for for a
long time I love the the Wii U um
Super Mario World and snarl and a 3d
Land um but this goes back to galaxy one
galaxy 2 sunshine on the miracle
original Mario 64 this is what people
been waiting for um and by all accounts
it looks amazing
though to me honestly
they hit it out of the park in terms of
that wow factor and a flooring people I
don't know if anybody saw the video of
people watching the conference from the
Nintendo World store here in New York
yes
and when that Metroid came up yo
bouncing in there like people were going
crazy mm-hmm no and then apart from the
direct afterwards during the treehouse
presentation then they announced more
stuff that they didn't intend to direct
this is when it this is when they
announced the Metroid Samus returns for
the 3ds um so I think the pacing after
after the the direct was great the fact
that they had more stuff to show they -
meaning knocked out of the park and the
booth was amazing the booth was jumping
and the booth made floor presence was
spectacular yeah I was your room not
give them a strong a - immersed a given
okay Lord you won't be getting an egg
for me for me oh what a dick now just
real quick before cuz I'm gonna jump in
next and I know like Kings coming after
me Oh what I mean but I why why couldn't
he get a from just curious I felt like
you know that they might have showed me
stuff but I felt like you can't you know
you can't show me half the perspective
you know there's still a lot of mystery
when it comes to them if they would have
came out there and had gameplay for like
a punk of mine maybe that would have
swayed me to give them that extra that
extra inch um you know they got a lot of
first party studios the fact that it was
25 minutes long maybe not want to give
them an A okay so you know cuz if they
would have made it a little longer they
could have shows more stuff got ya knows
what they wanted yeah I wanted to see
more on their online infrastructure you
know why couldn't you see myself on that
right now they ain't give any kind of
detail into why they're gonna be
charging $25 a year so I felt like these
missing questions it's not nothing
they'd show you know the stuff they
shown for the most part was good besides
you know the the sky and things you know
it's not necessarily anything get sky um
that's gonna do well on on you know yet
that's gonna do well where it is but
it's just the fact that
I played Skyrim on two platforms I've
put a thousand plus hours on the Xbox
360 I'm done with sky anyone who buys
scaring that's all them but I perfectly
but your personally you good you good on
s cash its outfit Javed um I think more
sorry ma our minds are melding it right
now oh man I mean I coming into Nintendo
such low expectations such low and
looking jokingly mixer and no disrespect
to the mentally disabled community but
we make a joke that it's like you have
that special needs child so whenever
they do something you like wow he did it
right so you come in with very low
expectations instead because they be to
the role drum right and you know not
attic nose like I was before that
started it was gonna be dog [ __ ] now
you're like Lord addict knows I stood up
for that pokemons direct I work nights
mean I stood up for that direct thinking
at a pokeymon is gonna get an ounce and
was thoroughly disappointed with that
entire show I had no confidence how many
to Nintendo's press conference I said we
going and then remember Lord Atticus
preface it right then they like oh it's
not gonna be 35 minutes it's gonna be 25
I'm like what are they doin like it's
bad enough
y'all got a press conference a legit one
then you're shortening the direct like
so coming into I'm lying intending
whatever right and oh baby
exactly so I'm very very disgusted
attitude I start to watch it and it was
just like mass body after body blow
after body ball they're announcing the
Skyrim stuff they're announced in Zelda
DLC we're getting a fire and a legit
game I don't I've never played a fire
him again I'll be honest the art style
of that game is tremendous it almost
reminds me of a fantasy star / wild
endemika anime kind of thing love
without what I seen from that
Xenoblade cool
nor that game is day one if I can even
believe that's running on them to me is
like I saw it on the floor as well as
well as the wreck and that game looks
amazing
Mario rabbits icing on a cake we already
know that's a huge step for Nintendo I
mean it was just body blow after body
blow of games getting energy for me all
these games are coming out this year
like I've seen me I'm like okay super
naari Odyssey October I might Rabbids
August I'm like okay this this lineup of
steady content to mention the Indies
that's gonna be sprinkled on all year in
these we're not even talking about the
past direct where they had the payday 2
they talk about they dropping this year
the NBA 2k to 5 all the third parties in
the mix it is you know arms drops after
the show you know right then in there so
I'm sickness with tuned to all stuff
that we kind of knew but if you look at
them as a whole 2017 almost every month
is a heavy hitter in summary moment so
I'm sitting and I'm like wait a minute
they've got the most content this year
it's not even a question like if you if
you go you put their monthly lineup
versus everybody else's monthly Lana
they have a banger for you whether you
like it or not if it's not your cup of
tea I get it but it's a banger for that
community and I mean so looking at it
and I'm just like I can't believe it in
25 minutes I'm left sitting there you're
like so for me it's I'm a surprise it
was by far the best show for me uh-huh
it was bright and I was it perfect no I
grew a lot attic yeah you know we would
like Nintendo to have a traditional
press conference we would like them like
if they'd have a traditional press
conference it'd be worse yeah yeah I did
the weirdness would be crazy didn't I
probably talked I think that up the
direct works because it's concise it's
like here's this game
boom here's this game let's go let's go
let's go let's go but not all I'm saying
but you know the only the only things I
left negative that I'm a deduct points
was like you said they didn't go into
the day
I'm party chatting we need to go into it
because as you know Lord I'd know on his
channel
you know Nintendo what the hell are you
doing this is a we need explanation on
the app functionality all that force is
also normally been screaming impasse
prediction shoves as far as arm you know
just how can I say like Virtual Console
needs to happen you know they kind of
knows before that they were gonna do
that whole you know almost like a games
with gold but you get in the tender game
I owned an NES game full online
functionality is cool it would have been
nice to be on the stage and that's why I
think having more time would have gotten
that out but overall I can't front lords
I'm giving up the strong a - man uh-huh
I was I was thoroughly impressed so I'm
gonna get my drink now I'm braced for
Lord Kings
destruction of Nintendo Hitler jig is up
the batter that though he has a lot to
say hello everyone and this is the part
where you know I reiterate something
that Laura Cognito said special needs
handicap if you will this is not a big
three type of race this is only a big to
race with the handicap Olympics on the
side um switch beautiful system let's
keep it real all these games that we're
getting are Wii U games there were
either put on hold or put to the side
and then start it back up and it looks
like Marcus army um so uh Nintendo has
all this wonderful content okay you have
all this chrono xenoblade's
yes it was coming off with you you have
this Mario game luck is ready to go it
was coming off a Wii U um you have to
zelda game that they had to put on the
Wii U because they probably made so many
roms of it that they couldn't just put
it out for the switch um
not saying that the content wasn't great
the directs are very controlled Nintendo
lights controls intended are control
freaks so whenever they are out in the
public it comes off as weird awkward and
unrehearsed a la ug sauce so what would
i rank the show based off a Content I'm
gonna have to give them the B+ why wait
a minute that is impressive for Lord
King I got a rep the reason why they
didn't get it a is back to Lord addicts
statements as far as the on line was not
broken down and explained I knew the
content was coming because I knew they
put a lot of they we use stuff on hold
not saying not taking anything away from
the content the content is great content
if it's on wiiu offers on switch but the
fact that is on a new switch it makes it
fresh and new and exciting I'm not going
to get caught up in that um same same
Nintendo always great stuff so the fact
that they were able to control the
direct I don't know how long ago that
direct was probably done a month ago and
he just kept doing a little tweaks and
stuff to it or post or thinking of
something I wonder if I want to get
Ashley this Lord Kings percent because I
think we completely dropped the ball or
something huge or how do we feel about
rocket League we didn't talk about
rocket League oh I was gonna end with
that oh sorry I was gonna end with that
um because the switch is showing when
they do content that is switch only
content not we you and switch content um
that the system is very capable as far
as like the FIFO FIFO oh you know for
those living in quality um it shows that
the system is very capable in handling
this current gems graphics alright so
when they show rocket league which is a
very social game which is a very online
heavy game that gave me hope for the
online infrastructure
the fact that they did reiterate last
night that they will continue to stick
with the phone as the cellphone will
bring a better experience when it comes
to their online chat system I was
disappointed in that at yes but again
Nintendo has been known to think outside
of the box and until I actually have
that product running in my hand I'm not
going to give any judgment on it because
they have proved me wrong in the past
and like they prove everybody wrong to
switch everybody said it would fail
everyone said that it wasn't be viable
everyone said why are you doing this and
then everyone's like I need one so just
shut up and let Nintendo do they thing
they're separate they're not part of is
not a big three it's a big tool and it's
just dude that's over there doing his
own thing he really doesn't care what
these other guys are doing because he
knows that he knows best and you just
have to go along for the ride you're not
in control is like getting the uber and
you're riding with a little experience
and you're not driving this ship is your
good thing let me ask you a question
looking cuz I'm floored by your ranking
I got to get o be anything from lured
chicklet it up gonna shed a tear right
now that means it moved you somewhere
yeah that's what my question is you make
a comment that you don't consider them
the big three right so what about now
that them beating to their own drum not
on the conventional stuff going so left
feel out of the norm but now having the
numbers to back it having the numbers to
say we're winning MPD does that at least
sway you that they're getting back in
the conversation as far as being in the
mix to compete for the title I can't be
in a big three can't be a big three when
you have inferior technology you're
always going to be a step on it you know
you always got to make concessions for
this other stuff so the stuff that you
see that will be broad based on the big
- they can't do you understand so it's
nice that you know the FIFA was looking
good
but was it graphically intense with an
anthem right not only not so but we
ended that doesn't matter
Oh guys does it right let that dead goes
back to my point they're beating to
their own drum but it doesn't matter if
you want to consider them as a big three
that it is not because a big three what
I consist of that you're able to either
run or compete if you can't even get it
to run you can't compete now this
question I will pose to you guys is is
anything that they show can that not be
run on the Xbox 1x absolutely I guess
what yes I cuz I'm gonna join us on that
absolutely buddy it goes back to what we
talked to talked about on our podcast
before we left for III where it's just
like I'm speaking purely in terms of
numbers right obviously it's the late
comer to this quote-unquote generation
so it's gonna be hard for them to make
up those numbers now in terms of them a
month-to-month winning from here on out
if they have the consoles in the wild
mm-hmm I don't I don't see I see it very
difficult especially for Xbox numbers
wise I could see people just on the
strength of the PlayStation name
continuing to sell well um and winning
some months towards the end of the year
but the new hotness at the end of this
year is going to be the switch that
people could not pick up early on in the
year right here and the Xbox one X now
the pricing of the Xbox one X prices it
out of a lot of people's range so that
leaves and then you have to assume that
anybody picking up a new console at the
end of this year probably already has a
ps4 and Xbox one
no those dollars are going to a switch
smooches I understand what you're saying
and you're talking about on a purely
numbers standpoint I'm talking about on
a purely competition standpoint
so we're diametrically opposed when it
comes to this a conversation because of
course numbers and sales wise is the
least common denominator when comes in
the money factor when it comes to the
money factor you're talking about
parents and actually have the income to
purchase that product and you're going
to go with a Nintendo type of
family-friendly mentality when you're
going
in and plus the fact that the built-up
height that says this is the must-have
thing equals sales so you will win the
argument in that aspect I will win the
argument in can they put anthem on the
system no can we put Mario on our system
yes so you know either way it's apples
and oranges did you have a great show
b-plus I'm not gonna sit here and lie
but do I consider them as part of the
whole no they are separate entity within
itself okay I see I see your logic
behind it I guess want to jump piggyback
off of a sovereign what say it - it's
just that I think I think yeah you're
right I mean you we cannot deny your
point look King that because they cannot
run certain titles like an anthem or
some others and house titles right
that's gonna matter in the long run that
may matter long and and may it's going
to disagree though this point you guys
are valid but they have enough first
party titles and stuff that they still
have on deck that to me they can survive
for two to three pass to two to three
year part I think a lot of people came
in initially saying okay one year fat is
gonna die out just like doing them not
you not you a lot of the Nintendo
community this is what I see because
remember switches me getting back on one
antenna I did not buy the Wii U so a lot
of the Wii U owners are like no not
falling for it this is the same games
I'm getting that I already had like a
lot of points that you made like a
cloaking so you know I think this direct
helped in the sense that okay you know
what
not only do we have consistent titles
throughout the entire year but guess
what Metroid Prime for you know I mean
guess what a dedicated pocong long game
so to me off the strength of their first
IPs alone that their longevity and the
fact that let's be honest these remix
games right
a remix Wii U games like the Mario Kart
whatever the Zelda that was original
they haven't yet developed dedicated
first party newer switch only versions
of said games which is the next sequel
so to me that extends the cycle even in
this Mario is a
you game which one are the Odyssey has
always game for the standpoint that
these games were put the reason why you
have inconsistent titles right now and
you consistent fresh titles because
these are canceled Wii U products but
not Odyssey I saw Odyssey was not built
on switch tech like they I've never seen
any confident information they would
they would they would never say that
this coding was done for the Wii U once
the Wii U failed that was a boon for the
switch yes as long as as long as they
pick to develop these games it's even if
they don't say it yeah it's it's safe to
assume that at some point that some some
version of Mario was on that on the Wii
U right um physical you can see our
games you can say that about any new
next-gen so it's not like own Xbox one a
ps4 came out we are getting a bunch of
BS videos right I think I think that
because this is that this how I look at
unknown switch boy go hard switch gear
yeah I'm not crazy with a crazy I'm out
here check it out but I guess what it is
is I just feel this a double standard
because when the Xbox one and the ps4
debut the first year and a half was
remastered game we didn't have any Heat
so what's cross junk is yeah like they
given us new IPs mix with remastered
games but there are gonna be pasta no I
know yeah I know where you're at
I'm just talking about to the other to
the section of the mindset that I see in
the Twitter streets where it's like you
know no I'm not buying it no you know
I'm not falling for it or no they don't
have any games or like there's just like
love carboxyl knows I'm talking about it
for in terms of the remaster thing and
people forget you know like I said well
we had that Xbox one we were getting
grant that photo mm-hmm all these
remaster I mean it came to the point
where shout the Lord angry man like we
were making videos about enough with the
remasters already
they were my peas in the beginning it
cook about year two year three for the
new IPs to finally come in and then
those guys tend to strive and what I'm
saying is with Nintendo which is
different is we're getting new IP
in conjunction in year one I'm getting
low power eyepiece because of the death
of the WiiU right and new IPs
because like there wasn't no arms before
that you can't say that one oh no no no
no no that that you can honestly say
that was developed for the switch after
I played the game and I see the game and
I said that it was very very like was
really a probably year to develop the
game good it's not one of those games
that was heavily developed and latent in
the corner hey no it's a nice game
price-wise I'm really not oh my
you're not finish taking afraid you know
that game is a 1999 game and they de
capitalizing over the lack of content or
lack of diversity in the content and
it's a new IP so yeah shout out to
Nintendo I just I just think IV up my
thing with your argument Lord King and
Lord addict is that it's that your guys
so you have a subjective view of what
competition is you're ready for you
competition is direct competition I
think at this point we've seen that with
the numbers that they sold thus far and
the numbers they they're probably going
to continue to sell if the unit's out in
the wild the third parties are not gonna
have an issue with pudding it's not a
long time party says no it's about the
hardware can't run this nut that
hardware's not capable this is fine but
not as one of the worst natural putting
those games on and talk about right
there then your two out here pudding no
but it is not the cavea because again
you're you're making a direct comparison
and you said yourself it's apples and
oranges right so here exactly so it's
like me the argument is right no wrong
that's what I'm saying
my thing is my thing is that competition
is going to happen regardless because at
the end of the day the dollars that that
is fighting for the same dollars and
that's my thing so whether it's that
it's not purely financial thing but the
dollars that are going to be spent I'm
gonna be dictated by the experiences on
there and like I said like all this
stuff that you're talking about they can
run on a ps4 Xbox
one the chances is somebody already has
a ps4 Xbox one are pretty high so my
thing is that by the sheer number of
consoles they're probably gonna sell
we're gonna see new and different IP
from obviously from them and from the
third parties also I think we're gonna
be surprised at what third parties are
gonna start putting out on this machine
and it's gonna be different from what's
on the other two machines but I think
again again that that's gonna create
competition it won't be direct
competition you're not gonna see do you
know you'll find your comparisons and
Carlos is gonna that's what it's gonna
create a segmented audience and the fact
that we I mean uh switch light is going
to when I was amazed at my FIFA for most
um it was because it wasn't a step back
right it was an actual product it was
what the hell they did it like so when
you stepped up to the plate roles like
oh my but it it it's but the reason why
you didn't see a need for speed on it
because they won't blow up back to your
argument is you're financially too and
dig the hell out of your pockets open
competitive wise they're not even close
this is my thing if in a couple of years
it probably won't touch Sony but if in a
couple of years in terms of console
sales if you start if you served Xbox
then are they not part of that
conversation
is there not competition month you stay
over with when the meat turf Xbox and
one one one what were friends do what
happens when make yarns of console sales
in terms of sale okay okay so you say
that there 16 million is equal to
PlayStation 60 million right no not down
took my place later sorry more about 60
million out now that won't happen your
PlayStation will be beyond that I'm
saying the date Phil I don't see I don't
see them you surfing PlayStation it's a
very real possibility they can you serve
Xbox mmm what's the 25 million with the
25 million so we're close to 30 million
right now and these guys got out for 6
million but you're talking about
Nintendo's worldwide appeal that Xbox
doesn't have
nothing right but and any insurance we
can't deny the fact that the Nintendo is
dominating Japan including Sony oh no
listen can I die in his argument I think
my territory you know this point it's
possible this argument is valid as hell
like of course those numbers is
fantastic whoopty woo don't you know
like the thing is think the thing is
this is very limited in my selection in
my purchase it's really planned out to
be honest with you whatever I can't get
over there I'm gonna get over here so
the triple a title at that Mary oh
that's cop all that other stuff is this
that's it right and that's for you
though that day then you got a dog
person masses that's right you got Tommy
yeah that mother brought him a switch
right so Tommy has no other choice but
to invest his his dollars and you know
ask mommy to invest his dollars in swich
enough it's good is it that's nice but
when Tommy goes over this big Jimmy's
house and big Jimmy is clear anthem and
Tommy can get anthem you're right mommy
is going to his mommy
yo what's up with this broad I need that
anthem in my life
so there's likely already has the system
that has eight ball she does like y'all
Augusta Jolie enacted right your little
khmer surin late in the game but doesn't
loud at all this I don't know I'm s I'm
not gonna say I'm not gonna give them
the the second console cavy I'm not
giving them that we talked about purely
off oscilloscope euerle office ills then
let's go toe to toe for these sales
let's talk this numbers then let's
really get at this right here let's get
at this wheel go in the store you see
this you say yeah I want that sell that
as elders fantastic but can I get that
same experience when I put on 0 horizon
gone yes I can because the numbers
dictate that they don't care they still
buying the system and it's allowing
those big horizons out sold at in and
the switches I'm selling this a week so
you want to talk head for head and
competition the damn
say right now MPD they're smashing a
Nintendo is winning that graphical game
did you looking for so you are the
minority yes exactly and I'm the
minority Lord of Atticus the minority
when it comes with what we're talking
about is it's in a dangerous zone where
this is the sweet spot they rocking out
right now but once everybody realizes
they hustled because it's a hum of them
afraid I'm gonna say that I've always
been the first person to you know I've
always been the first person to say you
know third parties don't matter to me
but I thing is when you go to and stored
and you're trying to invest into a
console to play games the switch is not
the first one but far by any means the
only reason people it's only reason the
panel here or saying you know third
parties aren't as on importance because
we have you know regards it's a PC
PlayStation Xbox we have another
platform to play those third-party games
on and that's where that's where
Nintendo is going to lack because you
know the Wii was a miracle the white it
blew up I don't think they'll get that
success again and so they can't support
these third-party support they won't
they won't even come close to the
numbers that they're competitions doom
let's move on to that yoga but no reason
see what will happen we all strongly
feel how we feel is this the conference
we talking about we got to a numbers
game and conferences the B+ will tell
you want for me you're not gonna make
they have a much Lobby that no we
couldn't move on from it we all agree
that we felt they had a Salazar and now
we left to the final two and arm we
gotta get off with a sony Sony is up to
back on the conference the impression
anyone can jump in on this I want to go
first being our here's being that up but
let's segmented today and um Sony's
conference is a solid conference I
thought they was gonna probably show a
little bit more the fact that the other
on friends didn't force their hand to do
anything kept them in a position where
they can just win they expounded on the
games that they showed last year so I
see this a lot of negative stuff into on
Twitter Instagram and stuff like that so
my feeling for them they get a B um the
concept that did this show was very
alluring very enticing I will be
purchasing a lot of those games when
they do come out again they stayed Pat
they were like playing poker and they
didn't have to you know double down they
didn't have to do anything they just you
know rested on their hand and continue
to go forward so they get a solid uh B
for me Nintendo edged them out with
their content with the fact that uh
they're showing more and Nintendo would
have got a so yeah I give Nintendo over
sony sony gets a B for not pushing the
hand when they could have jump in Lord
addict Sony I think Sony gets an a
simple because they had good pacing you
know for the most part there was kind of
the you know V ARS not my thing so you
know to me that was like a little bit
down downward spiral but you know then
they picked it up with you know the God
of War then they picked it up with did
you try any v ry use at the show yes oh
we actually we we actually did look can
you be impressed with us cuz I could or
I will like to know yo-yo your games
that you play that's for the after show
but uh so you know I like Sony you know
I do put them over Nintendo because I
felt like you know if I look at them
from perspective as a first
you know console they're just
automatically going to have the edge
over or something I play on the side if
you go home say and go you know Sony had
a solid conference you know I felt like
you know there's a lot of speculation
going that you know they pull [ __ ] from
the show and you know they they that
they poured it for PlayStation
experience look they they there's very
few incidents I feel that that would be
valid you know I do think 2013 was valid
I
think they went into that show with the
exact show they were meant to show a
week prior to that when they were
showing it in prayer and rehearsing it
III said it on iron Lords podcast has
said it you know on my own personal
YouTube channel I felt like they were
going to go out there stick to more of
their first parties and stick to the
third party marketing bill guns and I
was exactly right that's exactly what
happened and I felt like you know they
went in there knowing that they were so
far ahead of the curve they didn't need
to bring too much to that show I'm the
like Microsoft would one out there and
drop bomb after bomb that would still
would have been the show because they
know that at the end of the day they
still a PlayStation experience where
they generally announce more [ __ ] that
PlayStation experience they do at e3
that's where they announce the Last of
Us you know they so you know it's it's
how you look at it
PlayStation what their show stuff that
relative that that implies to me as the
hardcore gamer more than any other
conference to boom out say okay so um
just one quick but before I passed it
off to lots of home not attic what about
the argument that that is as from
hardcore game respected yes everything
that you said was accurate
they had greased up show what about the
from the argument that a lot of the
stuff still is not 2017 that affects you
in any way
oh I like people I mean you know it is
kind of weird that it was exactly the
same stuff as last year but let's be
real here almost every year Sony and
Microsoft rehash at least two to three
titles from the year before that every
year so you know I felt like that you
know they went out there and they're
like look it would have been a little
bit better if they had stuff for 2017
and they're like we're just showing you
what they have now and I felt like that
is one of the real low points that kind
of didn't make sense to me they went out
there acting like spider-man got the
drop this way and I don't like ending
with that game you know they took the
you know the cheap shot at Microsoft
which you know Microsoft clearly
deserved but at the end of the day it's
like I don't understand how you come out
there take a shot like that at your
competition show up a true exclusive
quote-unquote and then it says
coming in 2018 at the end of the trailer
like I like why like you giving them you
gave them eight all right you still give
them anxious it's it's like I said about
the you know the the show floor we're
comparing a bunch of great experiences
from least best so you know and when it
comes down to besides EA EA possess that
was not even nowhere near on that list
they both look for you and that there is
a rumor I don't know if you guys know
that Microsoft and Bethesda had a game
that they pulled from Bethesda's at the
last minute that's why Podesta's was so
short I don't know if you guys knew that
would and when it comes down to it it's
just like look regardless with Microsoft
show regardless Nintendo showed you know
I feel like the Tindall accommodated to
the people this year Sonia come to the
people next year if Microsoft come to
the people for the rest of the year and
the rest the next year look we'll get
into that definitely I'll figure
separate loss sauce ever learned a lot
I'd let let you finish this once you get
lost Ivan good oh all right he's good
loss off it's on you son I give Sonia's
a strong be um and I say this because
honestly to me Sony has always been that
company that kind of gets it when it
comes to e3 and like I said for me III
is about being wowed and Florida
surprise with stuff so I was surprised
that they kind of just went with kind of
showing more of their of their trip of
their triple-a titles that I showed
before and just you know giving you more
in depth game plan but not so they
really show much in the way of new stuff
on the monster hunter world it was great
to see that and by that it's a multi
player down on that stage um I honestly
was floored by the The Shadow of the
Colossus reveal I wasn't expecting it
that was really quick was his bro and
the fact that they're going to modernize
that and graphically looked amazing and
hopefully they fixed some of the control
things that kind of made the original
little and accessible to some people um
so that was great um honestly what I
think they did do very well was show off
their their first party the Uncharted
looked great the God of War is gone
where people were kind of iffy on what
that game was um they kind of expanded
on the game plan it looks like it again
it's going to be something that's great
in the main of the God of War is in the
game in the vein of the UH The Last of
Us and uncharted the third-person action
with you know additional like RPG type
elements and stuff um it look very good
on the Detroit looked amazing and
Detroit my god to you um yeah the
Detroit David Cades brick coming back
and trying to take the crown away from
until dawn um and then Spiderman looking
great
absolutely amazing so again they lean
strongly into that yes a lot of that
stuff isn't coming out now but you you
know you can be confident that it's
coming it's nothing's gonna happen to it
along the way
um what they did was make a compelling
argument for a lot of people to finally
pick up a pro yes everything they showed
was on a pro they've finally made the
argument like man this is why you need
this when you saw that day is gone
running that proof that you know that it
is a showpiece for that hardware same
thing they made it a compelling argument
I think for people haven't picked up the
are a lot of their BR games were great
on that stage are you talking about even
the final fantasy of the fishing the
Skyrim the urn the horror game the input
that the impatient that crazy looking
horror game the Bravo Team like they
have something for everyone they have
really something for anything so to me
again the only thing that the only thing
for me was it I wasn't floored by a lot
of stuff that I wasn't expecting on but
beyond that everything they showed is
solid and and again they made very
compelling reasons to pick up their
hardware from haven't done it yet so
just strong be from me F okay loss of
afresh shut up to the V I mention
because I gotta give apology to Lord
cake as you know I am NOT the biggest
fan if he are I still have my
trepidation I still have my concerns I
still don't see myself necessarily
picking one up just yet but I must say
as I get into my Sony impressions um
that was actually a stand out for me
because I felt the in the vo games look
great yeah and especially the the one by
the X Bungie developer with the little
mouse with the little mouse mark okay
much looked amazing you know I'm saying
so on shouting look nicodemus to the
chat baby I hate what get mega famous um
yeah it's like the VR again I'm so
skeptical that what they showed baby say
wait a minute
I may need to check this out and Lord
addict knows we was on the show floor we
checked out some VR stuff and I'm like
okay me Lord adequate days I was like
what do we feel we're like okay we don't
go figure of what but it went from not
having no interest at all to like okay
I'm a little interested so that's that
but I never feel let's get into slowly
prepress comments um me personally I
just felt that every title they showed
me connected to me emotionally as a game
Brian um Shadow of the Colossus was the
man test so I'm by to mean amazing come
on no every time I see God of War and he
says boy that's it crazy the other say
so it's like you know we got that the
day's going show new mechanics eyebrows
looked incredible yeah I'm just gonna be
traditional zombie horde Dead Rising
mana what I saw from it this time I saw
individual zombies within the horse so
they didn't just look like one you know
st. man glamour it I saw that you can
use it in strategic ways to attack your
enemies you know I mean so it's like it
was just I was just blown away and in
every mean I'm not even gonna get it
Detroit became human
mm-hmm if you all my xbox brother if
y'all I see this game you may feel some
kind of way I got a question
get him in more well I got a question
you're gaming more because if you gotta
sit there look at that game and say that
game don't you could make an argument
and we'll get into Microsoft I was on
the floor bro I saw that that yeah you
can say the engine
you can see you can say tell him there's
nothing better looking in my opinion
from a graphical standpoint then Detroit
became you - but it's not till toe is
way it is
whoa man again Sato shout out to send
your saves cuz we're going back at it
you know and he's like well you know
what the engine and scripted and all I
get it but until you show me a telltale
game with something of that Herc
that looks like that I felt graphically
that was there longer battlefront maybe
you know a couple others but overall I
mean I gotta say like Sony's conference
gets a strong be the only reason why I
didn't go higher because I'm so excited
is because the punch in the gut was okay
I took a step back mmm-hmm what's coming
out this year there right and we got
what was the the big one cuz God God was
two one two that come out this year
right what was the big one that's coming
out this year solve out of this Ottomans
movies the Gran Turismo grand uncharted
they're in a DLC right so when I looked
at God war all this other stuff on my
team I'm not getting one of those nails
I had so that way dad hurt so as
impressive as it was and the way I just
got to look at it was just like okay
like what attic said and we're gonna get
into Microsoft the way I felt they
played it safe they show the stuff they
needed to show they probably had some
things on deck depending on what
Microsoft did and because they may it
Microsoft didn't do those comment
sections going have all you might want
to pay attention it's all good with the
hope the whole thing is is just like I'd
I feel that it was solid but you got to
subtract from the gist the release dates
but other than that man I mean you know
I'm I was very excited about the place I
know I'm probably in the minority based
on the polls and all the other stuff but
I liked it yeah you come hoping the
Econo come but now it's not even a
little bit correct what the hell were
they help like does anyone know what
he'll play this
oh it's common then was sacrifice yes
endless sacrifice it's about that girl
who has like dementia and in she's like
she doesn't know if she's at
like enemies or not is it's kind of
supposed to be like this this kind of
psychological action thriller type thing
oh so it's a pass for me okay Oh coming
as digital only a matter of fact just
know that I heard about that one on
knack to actually fly it was on the
floor it was before but it wasn't at the
conference nobody's coming back in the
face to come every I'm being too calm
cuz they got big numbers from the snake
oil salesman so this we're not promoting
York rapid incremented ankle mentions
ninokuni to which is also big oh yeah
yeah and that is a that is a huge coming
this year right yeah that's what they
say so yeah oh yeah and regards to how
we feel you know with the whole destiny
to controversies resolutions content it
was on their stage they showed more
exclusive stuff there I like it
no but Sony has that you know I mean so
again it's compelling compelling
arguments to buy a pro like Louis offset
to buy these things because as the
controversy came out there's gonna be
for K 30 parity you know we met forceful
I know that's gonna be the comment
section saying well PlayStation has no
games really coming out the end of the
year that I want to play you know they
have persona they had no uh they yet
what we kick exactly have a very strong
beginning in Libya dominant first half
that they had mm-hm
neglect that so really they're playing
with house money they don't go they did
nothing
yeah they just could show you something
okay and that's it but we you know
that's what I got on a Sony I know we're
running off I want to get into the final
topic if everyone got Sony rock off
let's go this is the one we saving for
last the Microsoft
past crimes what do we have to say what
do we feel rankings and whoever wants to
send it off let's set it off
I'll go first alright I have been doing
extensive thought I watched it twice you
can
is he me Lord Cognito in lower David
were there lurking we're there so you
know I realized that when I watched it
the first time that you know you can't
really have a stable mind being there
with all the fireworks and olive oil and
all the atmosphere and the adrenaline
running through you and you know seeing
these come live you know it's not easy
to really have a rational thinking when
it comes to it
all right good if I would have put
anything with the big three I would go
Nintendo and Microsoft and Sony pretty
much head-to-head I would probably lean
more towards Sony because they have more
games that appeal to me but I'm not good
Microsoft too far behind them you know I
felt like the you know I was saying in
the Xbox Live party yesterday
I blame anchorman B I coulda had that
dumb back going on got the entire
community thinking this damn things
anything on and they start to get people
to legitly think this thing was going to
be 399 so when it was announced as a
$4.99 it that the Internet just blew up
I feel like that if Scorpio was not even
there it might have been better because
I feel like Scorpio ruin the show I feel
like the way they presented Scorpio hurt
the show I feel like the way they they
presented their first parties I felt
like that hurt the show if they would
have fixed how they did their first
parties not in they spent more time on
anthem they did there than they did the
game that's going to be debuting with
the caught with the X Dave four-day made
no sense to me I get that they want to
do games con that makes me think that
they might have an average games come
now because they're going to rehash [ __ ]
that was at e3 and at Gamescom that's
besides of one completely different
video so what do I think I think that
they had a very average very solid show
just like Sony but Microsoft at this
point right now with the criticism going
on about the the first party studios
that they don't have any first party
games right there was made it like yo
you can criticize us for that completely
valid because they did not go out there
show anything new okay then you get to
the third party you know I will say one
thing you have people talking about
versity the same people that are going
out there and you know you know being on
blood-borne you know being on these
these huge indie games it's not like
Microsoft took like the worst stuff
that's on Steam they took some of the
best indie games on Steam and you know
they that uh black des that surprised me
so I think they had a solid show I think
would abate it way better is if they cut
down so much on the titles they shown
showed more gameplay on stated ik age or
more gameplay on crack down chokes solid
presentations of the only games that's
that we know of that's coming out
besides see a thief because that was my
big issue I'm huge steady to keep then
people were sleeping on this game crazy
Microsoft you did not do anything better
to show people that this game needs to
be purchased not even a little bit
crackdown same thing you did not show
these people anything even a little bit
remotely that this game should be picked
up well you had Terry Hughes come out
there get everyone pumped and be like
you know what today you will be dropping
bombs tomorrow you could be dropping
buildings I did not see one building
joke I'm serious I did all of this to
make it Street the next day to say that
it's still their football touch now I've
been told that uh Phil Spitzer has
referred to the Nutella that you know
that that tells game the conquer look
looking dude he's referred to this as a
first party title so I feel like maybe
Microsoft has picked up this this IP in
the platforming in this game because it
came for an oculus game it's completely
been redefined to fit a console
experience I feel like that might be a
homerun I feel like they might have a
new mascot there might not be a huge
triple-a budget you know everyone's be
talking about but I do feel like people
will pick up a game for that franchise a
lot of potential here a lot I feel like
you know they're in a position where
they put all this all this this you know
they pretty much what I feel like
Microsoft did you know there's two
things I feel like they did one they
picked out some of the best Indies
that's possibly there that don't really
have anyone to speak for it's like they
went into the into the middle of an
ocean throughout a bunch of bait and was
like whatever
gets towed on radar now you're getting
that great analogy oh you okay - I feel
like this wasn't for the gamers first
off III is not for the gamers is for the
press third and I feel like because of
the 360 airing because the Matt the Don
Mattrick area people don't realize how
much Microsoft relations with foreign
developers have took in a hit because of
the Xbox one because of the ID program
restrictions when it first came up
because of all these programs they're
like look we are going to you put
anything that you guys want in the ID
program we're going to showcase it to
show you we need we mean business so
they're trying to repair that you know
then they're trying to repair the
Japanese relationships with Deb Phil
Spencer's one out there talking to them
that he's trying to try to get cuz let's
be real here games like um games like
Noah games like you know games that came
out on PlayStation it to be easier they
should have came out for Xbox too it's
not because people say quote they don't
sell uncle let's be real here they would
make profit let's they're not going to
not make profit I'm assuming it doesn't
cost more money than to make the port
for Xbox in a would that they would get
back in selves
it's these companies don't mess with
Microsoft that's the reason it's not
coming they don't care about Microsoft
first off so needs that lead marketing
they don't need a mess with Microsoft in
the way it seemed to me is these bridges
were burnt where they didn't want an
apple right and that's what the
relationship was stuff like uh idea Xbox
had to be created
you know when indie stuff was happening
and then if you look at the Scorpio
messaging to add on to your point what
addict you know when it was created a
lot of it was Pro developer they went
down and sat with developers and say how
can we make the tools better make the
engine bay dedicated to you so I
definitely definitely Mia culpa in terms
of getting those relationships but
continued and I feel like you know
people say put those as conferences
better than Microsoft as it shows to
good games and you say they got the
better conference it out here with that
nonsense and you know it you know Sony
had solid games they did you know but
when it comes to it like they had more
games that appeal to me and the reason I
see but Microsoft get more of an appeal
on Twitter and stuff
is Microsoft had like two genres of
every game a game in every genre in
possibly two to three you know they had
Dark Souls clothes they had racing
clothes they had a Mario Super Smash
Brothers clone levy they had you know
they had platformers they had
weird-looking guitar games and they had
something for literally everyone but the
own my biggest thing is how you gonna in
the conference with the third party Oh
satisfied that's my biggest thing and
you know that's why I said my Sony's
Sony shot was was validating you I don't
understand you know third parties can in
their title with third parties cuz
that's their platform but how is a first
party studio in a platform holder gonna
come out there and give the shine onto
another platform I know and that made no
sense to me like in people like whoa
it's the biggest blockbuster oh so they
go out there show a game with no hub
doesn't even necessarily look like it
might not even be gameplay I don't think
they've ever came out and said if that's
game play or not it'll foundry has
confirmed vertical slice for okay so
it's a vertical slice was pretty much
made in game it's made in the game
engine so how are you going to say
that's the biggest block but see this is
what kills me about people is it's like
the bait and switch it's like the
biggest beta switch you possibly be like
I get that this is then you know what
another thing that kills me I feel like
this game would even getting a little
bit a pool of destiny wasn't existent
and they're really going on to people
like well no one's calling this game the
destiny killer everyone is calling this
game the desert killing even if you're
lucky that we're already two and a half
hours into this [ __ ] or I would push you
in here most you like a marshmallow game
man
but anyway I'm no just distract it but I
did you get your ranking yeah what was
the rating you gave the Microsoft Office
how did you watch we watched it twice I
know how you felt initially TV watched
it mm-hm and a - Wow
well here's the thing I just nicked it
like you know like my biggest thing was
the first party the games that I'm
height for they didn't show light on and
I get that they want to save it for you
know more of a Gamescom but here's the
thing you only have e3 a lot of people
casual gamers watch III it's a huge
convention people know about it I can go
to an Xbox I party say yo what's III
there could be like dude that's that
conference that's in LA I can go to into
an xbox live high your casual people
like yo you watching games go what's
that yeah people don't know what I'm
doing lower notion of III years they
don't keep up question I got it but all
the things you seem to have a lot of
demerits on the conference right outside
of the diversity in this Cup so fallen
merits like for you to give it a day -
that's beautiful
that's a center way I feel about amber
that's pretty high
I'm actually surprised but I so I'm just
gonna give me the positive what what
Bush did there was he just a pure
diversity like it was you know it was
mainly a lot of Hope it is like you know
Microsoft it was feedback Microsoft took
all the feedback you know they've been
doing they're they're developing they've
been doing their software engineering
they've been fixing the dashboard how
people want it they're like look we know
you want Japanese RPGs we know this we
gotta agree without J Dragonball Z was
on the car on the Microsoft stage you
know huge and Ashton look phenomenal you
know it looked like oh my god and it
plays great it looked like a great Dark
Souls game with an aspect that doesn't
make it a clone because it's built
around co-op and that just says it
doesn't just have co-op thrown in it
yesterday they had really solid indie
devs I don't know if Nick Adiemus is
though in the chat but you got someone
that's a hardcore PlayStation dude that
he doesn't necessarily rip on xbox but
he's like look they don't have nothing
for me
this dude put the Scorpio emblem in his
name because of that conference okay
yeah not you being was both showing he
we had some talk cuz he was actually
yeah he was actually feeling might not
appeal to me on a hundred-percent
rotation but I was very impressed by the
way that they were like look and I know
the reason they didn't shall crackdown I
know the reason they shall static a
whole lot because they wanted all
those games in there and that's the
reason but I still have to think you
spent more time on answer than cracked
out and for that I can't give you more
than Sony I just can't cuz Sony did
spend more time you know it's like it's
like Microsoft but technically you did
know cuz you gave them hey wise you know
I say I gave I guess you know your Sony
yeah again somebody Sony a ok catch my
fault about it's like it's like
Microsoft when in like yo let me use
your easy it is and it sounds like I got
my Uzi I don't need to use yours got you
alright so look look King okay no you
call next yes yes that called next
because I just wanted
um you know to flesh out the thoughts
ahead of time like Lord our attic said
he watched the show two times i watch
the show two times as well i watched it
when i got back to the hotel and i
watched uh when i got home after i
decompressed while i was relaxing um and
being on the show floor it gives you a
different view of what's going on I went
into the show with a lot of preconceived
notions a lot of expectations or how I
thought the show should be done and how
I thought the show
[ __ ] and then how is she beginning how
everything should have interacted and I
was disappointed in that standpoint
while I was there now um after going to
everybody else's show and seeing their
screens Microsoft's presentation on the
floor second to none second to none
they're delighting the the screen I was
in fact likely they okay sweetie oh yes
yeah you're right you're right side the
the the the the ambience of it was so
incredible that it will make you take a
step back they showed you a Porsche I
know that really doesn't mean a lot ah
so many what it means before the premium
experience it means a lot for those for
the guys and all for the guys are in
force okay so it is the base
best-written IP that we have going now
it took the reins from gran turismo so
let's keep running with it and let's
keep pushing the boundaries yeah they
push the boundaries
Fidelity they push the boundaries and
gameplay they push the boundaries in
everything so yeah why not push the
boundaries in real world world and bring
a real life torch that's never been seen
anywhere on the stage only Microsoft do
it because the money is there for that
um now the way he feels started off the
show 42 games incredible uh when you
start to look at the diversity of all
set games there were so many games that
they really couldn't go in depth that's
why I said the PC show was a companion
app to this show mom it was so many
games when you go back and you see these
games you like oh yeah I like that
oh yeah yeah I like that you like so
many different games hey you were so
upset that they think yeah this is
eternal Lord King because that's enough
to have my wait what's that with that
and it was like literally a couple of
seconds and then move on and it's like
you said it almost felt like the PC game
ratio was the companion app because you
got a little bit more in depth with
those games they breed special intimate
games that did last night those other
games you know that shift those games
are fantastic ashen which I really don't
play dog soul games I brought blood one
for the PlayStation this action looks so
much fun look like so much fun and I got
a chance to touch I look they hate cuz
that the hit detection was off Lord
addict explained to me that in those
games timing is key timing is perfect
and he played it and he walked away from
that plays blood-borne and stuff like
that he walked away from it thoroughly
impressed when I knew Microsoft had a
piece of Lord addict is when he was
running around
the dish did after the show and fan fest
with a card and on this card was Halo
Wars - yeah and he was so enthusiastic
and I mean I can't express it enough
that they they they they got to him they
said you know we're gonna support your
game that you wanted anything vested him
and
show more DLC and that stood out to me
that made me say because initially I
gave these guys to see like all other
dudes they go there on the floor kill
the dead right but after seeing this and
then saying I let me take a step back
because I'm too emotionally invested in
Microsoft show Microsoft shown from
beginning to end was a quality top-notch
service now watching it at home on 4k
really brought about exactly what they
was about there was about the premium
100% experience if you're not seeing it
or watching it in that fashion you're
doing yourself a disservice film got a
chance to talk with Phil after the show
and I got a little bit more insight on
why they and didn't wear jobs and
illusion right that's that that's on
fact I have witnesses that was there it
was a business move and of course you
got it you got a piece everyone so yes I
would love the for them to have ended on
their IP which was cracked down which is
dropping date and day to this the
Scorpio decks um but they couldn't and
financially and business-wise remember
never forget EA axis is only available
on Microsoft System so that comes with
certain things you understand so the
fact that is still exclusive to them
speaks volumes in a partnership in a
relationship and then see everyone knows
and partnerships and relationships is
always give and take so that's where
that ended um okay you reckon my ranking
I give Microsoft an egg mmm I get
Microsoft an a4 content delivery control
pacing and pure hardware at the end of
the year the only developer and only a
console manufacturer that's bringing out
a console at the end of this year that
is HUGE
they and that didn't take away from all
the IP
even the different diversity of software
that they displayed so it was in
conjunction with the software so you had
hardware and software merging to bring
you that apex let me get right back to
my game of the show again which was show
perfectly a Microsoft format assassin's
creed origin spectacular Microsoft
showed it in all its glory it shined
brightest on Microsoft stage it was a
great game playable wise it was a great
game visually and I honestly know for a
fact that I'm gonna go pre-order this
game right now
and I'm not going to play it until I
play it off my xbox one X but that's
correct
Microsoft gets an a they don't get an A+
but they get an A and just like Lord
addict said hope and show and this is
remember Phil AP after Phil everything
after Bill is how we're going to start
chronologically saying this is how
Microsoft got back to the dev tippet
their position they start with our then
come in with the games and a narrative
is gonna start the ship oh can I can I
jump in there so uh right ahead
oh man you got odds of making some
points and I mean so many emotions right
now so I'm trying to gather it together
and I think a lot of attic Lord King
have made some valid points I think that
um I think being at the conference is a
negative in a sense in that when you
there you don't get a chance to really
experience it the way you should and
sometimes you know certain perspectives
are lost and I do feel that all the
points you made there's a lot of
validity to a lot of the points you're
making I did remember that this is like
cockney toes impressions and the Xbox
community and I would kind of at odds
let's just say that I would foot now and
that was from but I took a step back
watching.i here's what I'm at with it
y'all arm to me this conference was very
key this was supposed to be the
conference to turn things around you
know they're getting dominating the
first year this is the conference to
basically debut your platform this new
platform that we've been hearing about a
year and a half the chasis we're now
everyone's got Amazon Scorpios and the
Twitter handles you know this is the
conference right so personally for me I
did not like the price point I did not
like the release date I didn't like the
name o-x I felt was terrible I felt the
branding with Scorpio should have been
should have been kept did not like that
to me I rank these things because this
is the debut of the Scorpio this is
what's supposed to get people to turn it
around at $500 in my opinion you are not
getting a guy on the fence you buy an
xbox that's just me now is the hardware
worth it absolutely everything they're
pumping in absolutely as far as the on
the conference itself Lord addict I'm
with thousand percent with you
to me this was I'm gonna it feels like
I'm gonna hit you guys in the head with
all these games right I'm gonna hit you
guys you cannot say that we don't have
games coming for us that are exclusive
well the one out I loved it but on the
other note I felt hustled I felt ya
exclusive console launch exclusive and
it took me a while to I smoked the loss
rival or high bar to like what does that
mean what does yeah that it's yours
what does it mean that you drop on
Tuesday and the competition gets in on
Friday that doesn't resonate with me
here's my other issue I know that's much
community is gonna be very upset with me
it's just that this conference was solid
right to me they needed better than
solid
they needed amazing they needed the tips
of the you know the universe to say
Xboxes all the way back and I know I'm
in the minority here because the polls
say that Microsoft won the conference
but for Lord Cognito those gains as the
verses they are and I was happy to see
different titles and I've been
complaining about Big Mac large fries
shake and they show different stuff I
agree the issue I have is that
personally the games that appeal to law
Cognito were not coming this year no see
of these this year now okay longshot we
knew the game was an alpha okay um state
of decay was a huge blow to me as you
guys know I'm the biggest state of decay
fan for that to not be there okay it's
not it is it's not ready yet
not to be on the floor we can't touch it
okay maybe I jen has this IGN first deal
okay fine but dig going through those
games and lost sovereign mean you had
this discussion when we in the x-box
session of the flooring three did not
that the games are not good it's just
nothing resonated with me that i wanna
you don't have to buy something right
now this year as far as together i'm
hong kong xbox ted up to the core
i'm gonna pick it up but I want
Microsoft to win did in my opinion $500
in November seventh is not the move
that's not telling people wait to
November 7th to pick this thing up when
all the multiplier already out then it's
like okay let's be honest the digital
foundry stuff is coming out and whether
or not I don't want to get too much into
the controversy as far as whose fault is
it is the developers the facts remain
destiny to fork a 30 you know your own
first parties 30 frames per second or
crackdown you know saying Assassin's
Creed you got the marketing rights 30
not none of this stuff personally I
can't think the games are great I'm
going to play them anyway
but you have not made the compelling
argument to the public that this is why
you gotta buy the Xbox one X you made
people wait a full year so that you can
have parity to say I mean I whoever is
making the decision that parity
you know saying it's just not a good
look now the future is bright
I think Sony I mean sonic I think Phil
has a lot of stuff on on deck and I'm
calling at the scalebound effect where
he doesn't want to announce it until
it's ready because he doesn't want to
get you know chart and the last point I
want to make is that I think we have to
make a distinction between Microsoft
press conference and Microsoft Xbox fan
fest event no one throws a better event
than Microsoft period like it's just
amazing it's as far as the what was
shown great just not for me
diverse lineup for everyone else just
there for her video so it's not the
worst conference I give it a B I just
felt they needed to hit a homerun and I
feel I got a couple of singles up the
middle we played it safe
you know price I think was a misstep you
notice the Scorpio thing was a misstep
just as a whole for me I really felt
$400 you know September October that's
when you're coming for the throw that's
when you're competing November is but
that's me I know sauce has some points
on this I got my rant my rants off all
right well I think with me I think you
and I concur on a lot of our points I
think the first time I watched the
conference I was I was watching it back
in the hotel and we all know that the
internet over there was horrible and
spotty so that that kind of put a damper
on how I felt about the conference but
in general I just thought that the
pacing was a little weird and off of but
apart from that watching it a second
time at home watching it in 4k like like
Lord King said it really puts into
perspective um
what they did and to be honest I think
they did a pretty good job all around um
let me go with my cons first my cons uh
I don't necessarily would look on ito
about the price I get it
cuz I'm the one that wanted it to be I
wanted it to be four hundred so I could
speak to everyone and they could really
make it have a go at at going at Sony's
neck and they
conceded that they just said you know
what this is not what this is they they
spoke to us who they've already been
speaking to for years so you know 500
was to be expected Phil made it clear
that they could not have put out the
machine that they put out for anything
less than 500 so I understand that and
that's fine
um I think dropping the price at the end
of the conference was a mistake because
they they saved it almost as a money
drop moment oh my god thank you Andy and
it wasn't that um if my thing is if it's
500 you get out in front of that early
you say it and then you show me why you
charging me 500 for this console and I
don't think they did that um and not too
much which is real quick soft I'm glad
you because I forgot that point and
that's what pissed me off because you
know we waiting for the mic drop and
when Phil didn't say the price initially
you know I'm saying like I'm like oh
eight-day going for it that I said it's
for I said it's right it's for it myself
on it because at the end of the day
that's if it's five you've got announced
at first you got to get the sour taste
out of everybody's mouth his xbox one ex
with the nasty name and 500 on now let's
continue with the show guys so yeah I
thought definitely that was just a
misstep if it's five you say it first
and you just get it out of the way and
let Pete and show people why it's five
afterwards and they didn't make a
compelling argument for why anybody
needs to purchase that system other than
the hard core and all of us will in
already so it was kind of you preaching
to the choir already at that point um
the fact that they ended with anthem I
know it was a business deal but this is
your conference this is your conference
and you have crackdown coming out day
and date with the ex why is that not
your ending why I'm not showing
single-player gameplay and then showing
the destructive multiplayer gameplay you
showed before this is how you sell this
is how you sell that game this and this
is for a lot of people maybe a
compelling reason just to get just to
get the UM decks I mean they show plenty
of forza gameplay but they didn't show
they didn't show crackdown that was
disappointing I'm they didn't show
enough of crackdown all right um
i pros though to be perfectly honest
they he really knocked it out the park
games honestly when they show the games
during the during the press conference
you're a little underwhelmed because
it's a lot of smaller ID at Xbox stuff
indie stuff um but the big stuff did
they did show obviously the floors would
look great what I saw a crackdown I
locked I liked and I and that was I
liked even more after I saw it on the
show floor um
the Metro Exodus looks beautiful but
again that's that's probably an in-game
engine sort of verticals life vertical a
that's not it's not gameplay but it
looked
ah you know it to me it's probably very
close to what we're gonna get um in
terms of looks anyway um and then all
the idea at Xbox games they were on the
show floor obviously when you showed
them in a sizzle reel on screen it's
maybe not as exciting as what you want
to see but seeing all this stuff on the
show floor and getting to touch a lot of
it I mean these games are quality games
I mean to have you have pub gee that's
huge dude oh not true occlusive yeah
huge absolutely I mean super Lucky's
tale looked amazing path of Exile was
beautiful
I mean um the last night which you know
they they owned Inc only kind of touched
upon in their conference and then seeing
it again at the PC conference one of
them blew me away
so I mean when you talk about the battle
chasers the strange Brigade um that
other game that we played that was kind
of like a hero shooter the the Raiders
of the broken planet whoa look look
looked and played beautifully all of
these games absolutely beautiful so stop
trying to finish yeah quick question
though and this is in this is to the
guys all you guys with a diverse lineup
and this I saw a tweet from solid Rev
and red dragon and it's like all I'm
saying you guys are not and you're right
these are claw of the games I don't want
to disrespect the Midway all I'm saying
is you're launching a Scorpio do you
feel that these games showcase Scorpio
no not at all like what I'm saying
they're games they're amazing games and
as much as Phyllis talked about
improving the Xbox ecosystem
making it the best place to play adding
the game pass on that the changes
they've made to um Xbox Live I mean he
wants it he wants it over time to become
the place you go and you can have X
nominally a play I mean I'm what was the
EA service um he access ya access right
um so you just he's going to create an
ecosystem where anybody could come play
they don't have to invest a lot of money
and they'll be able to access a wide
variety of games and I get that I get
that but again these games were great
they played great I saw them first hand
they don't make a compelling argument
for this super powerful system they just
don't um and I think that's where they
failed well let see how it does
sorry to jump in that's kind of the same
thing as the pro we're starting to see
the benefits of the pro now pause the
beginning and I feel that that's the
same grandparents with this refreshed
thing that we all knew - you know
Microsoft is doing the same thing that's
just my opinion of it and again anybody
that purchased a pro and the beginning
for the price point and now that you can
get a pro at a cheaper price point or
fill jaded in that aspect we will fill
jate it the same way when Microsoft
actually starts to bear fruit with
having a more powerful console and the
price point is a little bit lower say no
no absolutely no you always if you do if
you're the first one out there you know
you're gonna feel it and you know if
there's nothing specifically created for
that console that you're just gonna get
you know better frame rates better
textures you know things like that at
the dough you're not really want to see
that big difference so again I think
they failed in that regard to present a
compelling reason why you need to buy an
xbox X if you're not us yeah um but but
apart from that they really did deliver
on the games um I'm excited to see what
new stuff and new first-person IP that
he said are coming but they are ways off
there's no point in talking about them
now it makes sense um it makes absolute
sense so I gave him a strong B+ okay oh
um one more thing to throw in there
sorry so the reason why the the destiny
is running at 30 frames per sec
Xbox 1x and not 60 frames-per-second is
being held back by the regular Xbox
right from the cpu in the parry I know
you got that exclusive yeah the regular
Xbox being that when you start doing
raids and stuff like that if you got a
guy that's playing xbox 1x and you got
the other guys is playing on a regular
Xbox if you running at 60 frames per
second competitively wise and all that
other stuff it throws the balance off so
um to keep it up the fact that the old
system if it was just this system being
launched and just played not
specifically then the game will be it
you know 4k screens per second Luke came
out and straight out said the pro
couldn't handle this game at 60 but he
kind of stayed away from that phrase in
the NBA
now we real quick we know could have
dedicated servers I see a lot of guys
Lord incoming away I gotta give it to
the no man I like the way you look I
like the thumbnail look if you like this
my son Dover DE Lord Anka because they
had a whole presence for us show this
year and they had a whole little section
that I think you two left with another
suitcase for all that swag just only
completely for a fall out it was
ridiculous oh my gosh me I was so mad
[ __ ] man I don't talk for a bit so I
want your hopefully brief impressions
I'll show has been kind of long but I
definitely want your impression you've
been dying chomping at the bit get in
here so uh I just want to learn [ __ ] I
hope you guys had a great
III I think of sending me does that
thing you guys have a lot of fun
absolutely we missed you too [ __ ]
well sure but you want to put something
up why we talk on some screen share cuz
I thought it was funny
mmm well that's gonna load anything I
need I need those depressions yeah hi
specifically Microsoft
talk to me haha get talk to people see
it yeah
Oh
oh my good yeah I was in her precious
she would be three this year because I
wasn't I had been there before if I
wasn't there this year and sigh I was
looking for something but I think of III
was I just wanted to see from Microsoft
I wanted to see something that was
competing against the narrative the
narrative the Microsoft only cancels
games and they are making anything new
anymore I wanted to see something to
compete against that and a new game
women perfect yeah just some and I get
there wasn't anything ready but there
just had to be something to get you back
in it and so really you can either have
a show that focuses more on hardware or
a show that focuses more on software and
when they went with here's all these
sort of exclusive games Oh party I
thought they were gonna really bring it
with the the hardware and I thought and
the big thing was when they didn't
announce the price I was like oh crap
here it comes
zit this is a body
I'm Jeff Keely going out there and
spoiling the price oh good point good
point I do have a question do you guys
think that was a controlled spill in
Microsoft ask them to do that going on
this real quick and I'm not one to
disrespect any journalists or whatever
but I felt with Geoff Keighley did was
so unprofessional slime ball and it and
slime ball and to be honest you know I
don't know how Microsoft relationship
was gonna move go with them moving for
because at the end of the day you know
these are huge tidbits and to me that's
like bush-league it was kind of like why
would you announce their price before
they do I didn't get the logic behind
that like what was he doing like oh
you're scoring points with the gaming
community because you yes you are
correct that it was 500 but like why
would you spoil a press conference in
that way that was a huge thing that
people want them no I don't know how you
guys felt about it but I was very upset
with Jeff Keeling with that I mean also
the same time Microsoft tried to hide
that they really did
like his no jobs keeping leads away to
the og backwards-compatibility
like he does in consequence - Rollins
you can play all this
now that was like that that oh no I
don't understand why he did that um but
um his announcement and I was while we
were standing on line you know for the
fan fest his announcement that went out
was very unprofessional and like I go
out uh kognito said I don't know how we
move forward even dealing with that dude
I don't I don't give him any traffic
towards this I don't watch another his
stuff anyway he always came off as a
slime ball to me opportunist and he just
showed exactly what it was you know for
the right price or whatever he will
compromise his integrity to put that
information out now if he was directed
by Microsoft to put that information out
to defuse something I think that stupid
I don't see the validity in that I
actually think he did it in a in a
spiteful manner maybe he doesn't get
cycles live it's like crystal it's like
what sage said he said he thinks he did
that to get on neogaf to go on ready to
get that you know minute of Fame because
a big person here in the industry like
him is safe without a doubt this is the
price and what's crazy is about the
whole situation he's never really done
anything like that in the past and he
actually getting snappy because when
people would say hey you may be wrong
whatever whatever cliff from Destiny to
actually said what you guys are saying
which is he did that oh this time wild
theory that you know Jeff is doing this
to you know to lower expectations and
then Mike's was gonna come out with real
price or whatever whatever and then he
fired back at Luke Smith from Destin
said okay if my price ain't 500 they
were not you interview on my show you
better tell me what if Xbox is running
60 frames-per-second destiny and I was
like wow like my nitro Geoff Keighley
like I didn't get it I didn't get it
contending to spite him they should have
dropped it by twenty dollars by fives by
$5 they should have dropped it he said
4995 and despite him mm-hmm
continue was really like man like and
that's the thing though but like also
someone else pointed out you know what
he did about ten minutes afterwards
which I'm
yeah advertiser the DJ's oh but uh he
got it hey all attention was on him and
hey the VG eights are coming out later
this year like they're related
there's overall your impressions of
market social but um yeah I think
Microsoft's gonna be kind of keeping on
a little more arms link from now on
because of that and yeah but that's a
side thing and I I wanted to see the
show as I want one be one new game from
you one one new Triple A game riding
kind of like focus on and think about
and they didn't have anything so slow
not a single brand new triple-a game for
you right at me you're the same mindset
okay
yep well I want to see one thing that's
it it could be it could the teaser it
could have been something I don't care
as long as it was a brand new game to
show off and they just didn't have
anything which really pissed me off and
I was like okay you're already gonna
come in there were five hundred dollars
but what do I have to look forward to
back down you mean the thing you didn't
show me the authority which nobody cares
about the story in crackdown it's all
about the destructibility in running
around well before about if you showed
us nothing mm-hmm then after that then
it was oh well we got Forza okay same
video window and then for those who
aren't it's not horizon so I don't care
because I mean I only play the rising
series I don't care about the
Motorsports top somewhere - I'm one
thing goes on everybody's s worked over
yeah we'll finish anchorman now you're
the big anthem guy because we know
you've deemed it the destiny killing
upsetting all the Lord oh man my mom
even with the anthem announcement cuz I
was the new IP that a lot of people
really raving and saying you know it won
the show for Microsoft stuff like that
you know did that tilt the scale for you
or you still be you know with the 500
and you know where you're at with that
relationship to anthem the anthem thing
I don't even view as a Microsoft thing
thank you I guess a lot of the stuff in
your platform person with your new
platform anything you show on stage
better be exclusive or it needs to have
some sort of relationship with you but
like something tangible at the same time
but like when you should a third party
game that's is not it's not coming like
timed or anything like that it's just
they're like yeah might make for a cool
show but doesn't the exam please gotta
have like you know like huge marketing
exclusivity to you know I'm emailed you
know like like if I don't have none of
combat you know destiny was Sony that
makes sense why they'd be on their stage
because there's a huge relationship with
them too but like if you just coming up
there just to premiere your game like
that makes no sense to me yeah yeah like
okay like Metro Metro I was geeking out
about real hard when they showed it
how's that so cool which is not
exclusive it's not bonus ones for
Microsoft
I can give Metro a little bit because
I'm like you can show your game on the
stage if your brain is more intertwined
with that like a splitter so I wouldn't
be surprised at that showed up you know
a Bioware game you know it does make
sense a little bit because you know they
know that's one of their biggest Idol
I'm like I don't give I don't give
points to Microsoft for getting them to
be on stage like boom just got them
there that's it that's all you need
I don't you don't get bonus points
because you just got them on stage I
mean okay like okay here's an example
Shenmue 3 Sony got Shenmue 3 on stage
and when's that coming out I okay nobody
understood that that oh nobody
understood that the Beyond Good and Evil
sound like a Kickstarter
without them
they did something bad so that that's
where I was kind of sitting on like a
lot of sub Microsoft showed anything
that wasn't any like those console
launch exclusive there was no point of
having it on stage
to me yeah like I should have it on
there like for to kill time but like
Anthony I enjoy the I enjoy watching the
gameplay and I I really am digging that
game for one reason only simply because
that game reminds me of titanfall yes I
will I'll give it the aesthetic so close
saw your video
yep it got me so I'm interested now I
gotta see the game the body where
something in which is huge
yeah like John what thing I'm onto right
now is apparently there's gonna be a
healer class and a dedicated healer
class and there's like there's a couple
pictures floating around like there's
actual whole channels and stuff like
breaking down a single frame into a
10-minute video mm-hmm yep it's like
you're overanalyzing the [ __ ] out of
this right now but but it's interesting
like there's a lot of really cool stuff
in that room
and like I made my own little video
about like what I think they could do to
be a destiny killer but I i sorry to
that I just I was actually very good you
you actually back balance so I like that
but look I don't we went we went on you
know what King unfortunately had to step
out you know it's Father's Day so we
kind of want to wrap this up so real
quick just gonna go down the line um
through everybody and then we're gonna
close this thing out as far as our
rankings from best to worse or worse the
best off you guys want to do it and
let's start since I got many jumping
late let's start with you as um all the
conference's the big three and then all
Ubisoft EA and your favorite Bethesda so
what your rankings are all right ranking
from worse the best worst was EA there's
no point in having a conference as usual
like if they had if they had anthem on
stage then I would have said there was a
chance but
they gave it to my test technically they
dated and they said watch the Microsoft
conference for this yeah there's no
point in watching anything from EA
they're the worst um uh who else is
there we had on Sony Nintendo Microsoft
me so I gave like EA a D and then
Microsoft and Sony are tied um I gave
them both like a C Lenny just passed
like with Mike Microsoft in particular
was it was the conference they deserved
but not the one they needed and so and
say and Sony just didn't show anything
new either there's some gameplay of
stuff we already knew about and no
release date again right now correct so
um what about Nintendo will be stops
wait with him then I got Bethesda just
AG C+ Wow b-minus
it was short to the point I know they
pulled starfield I know for a fact they
pull starfield
the thing was 20 minutes short but
Wolfenstein is amazing
so just barely above it and they didn't
make me wait until 2:00 in the morning
um at least here um what else can I give
you thought with a be okay Ubisoft like
they showed off a pretty solid showcase
in comparison to everyone else yes um
and they showed games they're making yes
and like it was pretty good pretty good
variety to it like there's some things I
didn't like some things I did like when
I go forth and even taking the whole
Mario Rabbids thing yeah it make you do
a thing that people are enjoying and I
think Nintendo had the best conference
whoo - a new Kirby game a new - new
Metroid games just don't stop yeah
Nintendo was short sweet and gave you
stuff no one thought Nintendo was gonna
come out there
nobody thought was in the only five
minutes 25 minutes short and I I thought
I counted them out I thought it was done
III was done after Sony went but I was
pleasantly surprised so that lets me
look Louis office rankings rankings uh
from worst to first
Bethesda last and followed up by ei then
Ubisoft uh then some of the big three I
would give Sony um my number three
ranking my number two ranking goes to
Xbox so Microsoft um and yeah Nintendo
Nintendo Nintendo did with what I feel
III is for and is to be proud and can be
blown away um and you know just just
that Metroid announcement alone was
enough to say blow me away so yeah so
Lord attic you ranking uh Ubisoft PC
conference uh I'm giving Microsoft and
Sony you know the same thing yeah I'd
like to say Nintendo won but at the same
time I gotta take I gotta take in the
consider factor the third party thing so
I'm not to say so many one Microsoft
right behind them and Nintendo right
behind them and there is I didn't but II
am but designated they didn't have the
show so well yeah I'm think it was kind
of similar I have but that's the last
unfortunately home the DLC stuff didn't
do a really glittery kitty oh but
there's some cool stuff I just felt like
needed a warning to show um above that
probably um yeah he D trailers is all
pretend I'm a sports guy so EA you know
has some sports stuff and switch stuff
with resonated with me um then I was
probably I'm probably gonna go Sony as
much as I loved it just what heard it
was the um know what you call it um you
know the release date stuff all now did
is this weird mix between Ubisoft and
Microsoft for me which is kind of like
they fall in that same kind of character
but I felt will be social
was I just feel that Microsoft had more
volume for everybody so it's kind of
like that little tie they're going on
with that and then I got Nintendo yes
number one I mean I ain't completely
knocked it out the park short sweet
essence of stuff that it's coming out in
2017 that's this year and I'm very
excited for the future for them so I
think they they made people they gave
people a reason to buy the switch now
you know that's how I felt about it so
that's how I got it and again we
apologize for going extra extra long and
a lot K had to get out of here and happy
Father's Day everyone
so just gonna do these outros super
quick if we can lure dad my brother from
another mother what's going on with you
we could it be to find you what's
happening you found me on Twitter Lord a
coyote you can find me on Xbox Live you
know any kind of gaming
surface it's it's bring to kill I
definitely tune in Tuesday for the
planet xbox me uh my kids news podcast
and I'm the co-host on there also but
yeah it was a good show thanks uh lord
anchor for showing up mmm absolutely and
uh Lord sovereign Wiccan franken-fridge
first of all happy Father's did
everybody um definitely can find me on
xbox live at being sovereign PSN BX up
in one word and on Twitter um Lord stop
IOP oh and a quick shout-out that I did
mention before Tim dog I met Tim dog on
a flight back from LA
your eyes that are the team dog very
nice guy mm-hmm good people's good
people's no doubt and our last-minute
guest Lord anchor may not be find you
there's no point in trying to find me
anywhere here's knows who you are Jacob
everybody if you're watching this just
subscribe I think you happen guys
thank you sir always appreciate you
always the day one support always show
love and definitely miss you this your
hopefully coming back next year the
right eight three minutes when I read my
second but hopefully you check him out
on a multi version he's always putting
stuff out top shelf
and also that tick
Network all the tech guys showed
tremendous love and of course it is I
nor Cognito here you can find me on xbox
live as Lord kognito it's no longer
comedy it is now Lord kaan you know so
you can find it in swich gang you know
I'm not giving you the social security
number for all of that so we're gonna
have to send you the Amazon but make
sure you guys subscribe like I
appreciate all the support and again we
apologize for the way you got a lot of
things cooking and on that note we are
out of here but if you didn't catch any
of that everyone's stuff is in the
description hey no doubt and we have
peace